hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will go through the business
system analyst full course for 2023 and
discover the intricate role of Business
Systems analysts through a comprehensive
course learn to bridge the technology
and business analyze processes gather
requirements and design solutions to
optimize organizational efficiency
Master the art of translating user needs
to influential functional systems
ensuring successful project outcomes
together in this business systems
analyst Phil course we will learn the
following first we will learn what is
business Process Management followed by
that we will go through what is business
analytics next we will Master the
fundamentals of business Process
Management then we will understand who
is a business analyst next we will dive
into steps describing how to become a
business analyst in 2023 up next we have
the perfect business analyst roadmap for
2023 next we will discuss the top 5
business analyst certifications next we
will learn basics of project management
followed by that we will go through the
jira software which is one of the best
project management tools and some of the
10 essential interview questions and
answers on jira followed by that we will
have Tableau in-depth tutorial along
with Netflix data analysis project using
Tableau followed by that we will be
covering power bi tutorial for beginners
and followed by that we will also go
through some introductions and some use
cases which will be Carbonic data
modeling in power bi next we will go
through business analytics with Excel we
will also cover the Excel macros and VBA
for beginners up next we will deal with
SQL Advanced tutorial for business
analytics next we have a brief
introduction to business analytics with
r we will also deal with some critical
use cases of business analytics with r
and finally we will deal with some
important and most frequently Asked
business analyst interview questions and
answers let's embark on this
transformative adventure together I hope
I made myself clear with the agenda that
said if you are an aspiring business
analyst looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program and
business analytics from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below also
if you are already a business analyst
and want to upgrade your skills to
become a successful data scientist with
proper training and certification from
the experts and reputed universities
then Caltech data science bootcamp
should be the right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
like share and subscribe button and the
bell icon to get notified also before we
get started with the business systems
analyst full course let's hear from our
Learners about the personal experience
and their success story after getting
graduated from the business analytics
post-graduate program offered by simply
learn from Purdue University I have
always been passionate about learning
new things and improving my teaching
skills about five years ago I realized
that I have a gap in my knowledge and to
fill the Gap I needed to skill myself I
chose increment at my upskilling partner
because of its comprehensive curriculum
and its connection with Urdu University
how
my name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington in the city of
Kentucky in the United States
I am an assistant professor at Midway
University and I hold a PhD in
management human resources and
Leadership
I decided to opt for the post graduation
program in business analysis from
simpler which has helped me a lot to my
professional and personal life
I have been teaching even before I moved
to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
it was very difficult for me at the
beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis and
starting in Fall 2023
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
if you see how the business works is
changing now and you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the change everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing with that in mind over
to our training experts let's understand
what business Process Management is
business process management or BPM as an
organizational discipline in which a
firm examines all of the operation
processes collectively and individually
through this assessment companies aim to
identify areas of improvement to create
a more efficient and effective business
environment in simple terms business
Process Management is all about
optimizing and improving companies
business processes that serve customers
and eventually bring the pile of Revenue
BPM is vast discipline that by
definition is dynamic given the
continually changing organization roles
regulations methods corporate goals and
other Factor it contains BPM has evolved
with time to accept a wide range of
optimization approaches from Six Sigma
and lean management to a child we'll
discover these approaches in depth on
some other day first let's dive deep
into the details of BPM if we break down
nuts and bolts of business Process
Management you'll find out three key
factors the first one is of course
business processes the second one will
be the set of inputs and the third one
will be the output retrieved after
processing presented inputs for example
consider the bank loan application
process here the customer will supply an
electronic application form via the
bank's website to receive the desired
loan plan let's say a home loan in this
case initially the input provided by the
customer will go into the loan
application process now the loan process
is not one small process there are
multiple operations and regulations
involved in it such as credit checkups
quality control loan management
underwriting
Etc all these tasks are cumulatively
considered as business processes as
mentioned earlier all these processes
will start once the customer provides
some sort of input in this case it is an
electronic application which will be
forwarded to the salesperson by Banks
ITT by evaluating the submitted
electronic application A salesperson
will formulate the list of loan products
in order to present them to the customer
but if a customer is interested in some
specific banking product for instance
Home Loan in such a case the sales
person will provide customer details
about home loan a home loan has certain
eligibility criteria which customer will
have to fulfill so salesperson will ask
for setup documents such as ID proof
income Source or salary slip property
documents Etc this initial phase of loan
application is also known as
pre-qualification process
in the next phase the administrative
team will evaluate all the documents
submitted by the customer and forward
them to the credit analyst system at
this point the credit department
receives the application and the first
step is to analyze it for accuracy
genuineness and completeness
if all the needed fields are not filled
out the application will be returned to
the borrower or credit analyst who will
contact the borrower to get the missing
information
the credit team uses the loan
origination system to determine a
borrower's credit worthiness a good loss
will help A lender Bank set up workflows
to process a loan it may automatically
flag files that have missing needed
fills return them to the borrower and
tell the sales department that they need
to be reworked to manage this Tech a new
Department of information and Technology
will also come into play this particular
step of application evaluation is also
known as underwriting process in the
next phase the credit decisions are made
if customer fulfills all required
criteria the application will be
approved or if the customer lacks
somewhere the application will be
rejected in the next phase quality
assurance will be achieved because
lending is highly regulated business
Banks rely heavily on the quality check
states of loan origination process the
application is routed to the quality
assurance team which Compares crucial
variables to internal and external
standards and regulations this is the
finest type of loan procedure before it
is submitted for funding now consider
all these processes altogether each
process works on feedback of other
process or some new input hence managing
every input and process can increase the
speed of business operation by removing
internal miscommunications service
delays customer complaints Etc and PPM
is the field of management that exactly
Works towards achieving that in short to
Define it in more simple terms I would
say BPM is all about managing multiple
input streams and intercommunication of
business processes to generate desired
business outcome within the least amount
of time possible
this BPM comprises of three main pillars
people processes and Technology all
three aspects are required to work hand
in hand for a BPM project to be
successful the business process needs to
be fit for purpose and actually
satisfied the demand for all the
stakeholders having said that let's
discover the life cycle of business
Process Management
technology and management both are
crucial factors for BPM so the life
cycle commences the collaboration of
both with five standard steps the first
one is design then we have model
implement
Monitor and finally optimize
a large team of I.T and management
experts is required to construct the BPM
project
the management team will study related
set of business processes in great
detail and then try to redesign it with
the objective of optimizing it so that
it becomes more purpose oriented all of
this happens during the design phase of
the project here all the processes are
carefully designed to be as
straightforward as possible by making
use of standardization and it automation
that is why the space can be completed
in a shorter period of time next we have
as a modeling phase
during this phase the process gets
documented in the form of an activity
model it allows experts to simulate the
system's behavior and try out different
scenarios through a what-if approach
once the process is approved by hire
management by looking at the modeling
and simulation sheet it is then executed
and deployed over the information system
this phase of business Process
Management is known as implementation
phase here if management finds out some
discrepancy the corrections can be made
by employing standard methods and
automation
the fourth page of BPM is monitoring
in this phase the performance of
business process is monitored to see if
anything goes wrong
if any problem occurs during the
monitoring phase it will be further
optimized in the next phase of business
Process Management this phase is known
as optimization often this phase remains
continuously under the Run since the
good BPM always improves its business
processes on an ongoing basis moving
ahead let's talk about the benefits of
business Process Management
the first benefit is increased
visibility of business processes a good
BPM implementation will increase the
visibility of banks activities making it
easy to Monitor and control the critical
business processes of the bank
vpm also provides management increased
ability to identify bottlenecks in
simple words a process bottleneck is a
work stage that gets more work request
than it can process at its maximum
throughput capacity an example of a
short-term bottleneck would be a skilled
employee taking a few days off
if this occurs planned operations will
not be done on time leading to the drift
in business performance the other type
of bottleneck would be a long term
bottleneck it occurs all the time and
can significantly slow down production
an example of long term bottleneck is
when a machine is not efficient enough
and as a result has a long Cube BPM can
help companies make improvements and
reassign resources to meet customer
demands by identifying this bottlenecks
the next benefit of BPM is reduce lead
time by controlling all business
processes altogether and monitoring each
process in a silo BPM increases the
accuracy and speed of business
operations for example the loan
application process that could have
taken months can now be finished within
weeks because of Control process
handling by BPM this increase efficiency
allows Banks to convert leads into
potential customers with no time so
definitely this is the hottest benefit
that BPM has to offer
the next benefit is a clear definition
of employee roles
a good BPM ensures planning Optimum
roles and duties for the teams as well
as employees since people resources is
also the important factor BPM aims to
manage the BPM system prevents
unfortunate situations where a customer
who phoned to inquire about a loan
application is transferred from one
individual to the next and next with all
of them saying sorry it's not my
decision to make but let me transfer you
to the person who deals with it BPM
enables a cross-functional approach to
avoid this scenario so the work is
automatically moved from one disk to the
another without any need for manual
intervention
the sixth benefit is Unified systems and
operations since in BPM no process
remains in a silo by itself all
processes come closer to each other
making business a complete unified
system
the last benefit on our list is expanded
growth potential as discussed earlier a
successful BPM increases customer
happiness and Lead conversion which
directly increases a company's revenue
and market value
it is no surprise that business
analytics and business intelligence are
two of the fastest growing markets in
the world organizations today are
generating data at a rapid rate there is
a need to use this business data and
make smarter decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence of bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively
consider this example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
Texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
Spike up in Texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in Texas who like to make
chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using Cutting Edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth business analyst
is a professional who is responsible for
Bridging the Gap between I.T and
business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills
the skills for a business analyst are
not only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations and the
motive behind the problem so let's have
a look at the top skills to become a
successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increase in marketing budget according
to the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill of business
analysts should have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says five percent of
the people think 10 percent of the
people think they think and the other 85
percent would rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders non-verbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority as the
project progresses negotiation skills
help to determine the functional design
which fulfill the requirements technical
decisions also require negotiation
skills business analysts also perform
cost benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have an act to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
well some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation date of wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deeplyer titier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
now business analysts should be
proficient in using various business
intelligence tools for creating reports
and dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualize Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth skill in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution now let me ask you
guys one interesting question what is
the primary goal of conducting a SWOT
analysis option A identify market trends
and customer preferences
option b accessing the financial
viability of a business venture option C
evaluating the internal and external
factors impacting a business option D
developing strategies for product
development and Innovations please
answer in the comment section below and
we will update the answer in the pin
comment you can also pause the video
give it a thought and answer in the
comment section now let's dive back into
our video business analysis is like
being a detective for a company it helps
a company figure out what it needs and
how to make things better business
analysis is done for all sort of things
a company wants to do whether big or
small it can be a part of specific
project or ongoing as the company grows
and improves think of it this way
business analysis helps a company
understand where it is right now where
it wants to go and how it gets there
it's like looking at a map and planning
the best route for our journey it's
important because it helps the company
make smart decision and find ways to
create value for the people involved
so if you are into solving Mysteries and
helping companies grow business analysts
might be the perfect role for you
so till now you must have gotten an idea
of what business analysis is now we will
see who is a business analyst a business
analyst is a person who performs
business analysis tasks described in a
bab okay which is the business analysis
body of knowledge
no matter their job title or
organizational role business analysts
are responsible for discovering and
analyzing information from a variety of
source within expertise including tools
processes documentations and
stakeholders
now let's see what business analysts do
the activities that business analysts
perform includes business analyst
understanding Enterprise problems and
goals analyzing needs and solutions
formulate strategies Drive changes and
facilitates stakeholders collaboration
moving ahead with the positions that we
have in the business and let's discuss
with the education and skills needed for
the career path let's begin with
discussing the typical salary range of
an entry-level business analyst position
it's important to keep in mind that the
salary figure depends on various factors
such as location industry and Company
size however we can provide a general
idea of what you might expect
for entry-level business analyst in
India the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is typically between 3
lakh to 6 lakh per annum and in the US
the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is approximately
between 50 000 US dollar to seventy
thousand US dollar per annum
now let's see education and Foundation
first you will need to get a bachelor
degree in business and administration
computer science or relatable feed it's
like building a strong Foundation of
your career to boost your credentials
you can also consider getting
certifications after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes it's
like becoming a problem-solving
superhero now hands-on experience to
really level up look for internships
entry-level positions or projects within
your organization this will give you a
practical experience and allows you to
contribute to the requirements Gathering
documentation and testing it's like
going to on a real life mission and
making a tangible impact by following
these steps you will be well on your way
to become a skilled business analyst you
will be the hero who has businesses make
smart decision and drive success
now let's talk about senior business
analyst salary
for senior level business analysis in
India the salary range can be between 6
lakh per annum to 12 lakh per annum
in the U.S the salary range of a senior
business analyst is typically between 70
000 US dollar to 100 000 US dollar per
annum for education and Foundation
consider pursuing a master degree in
Business Administration or a relatable
field to depend your knowledge and
expertise explore Advanced certification
such as certified business analyst
professional or project management
professional acquired domain knowledge
continue expanding your understanding of
the industry and its strength challenges
and emerging Technologies develop a deep
understanding of specific business
domain with the industry
next analytical skill development
enhance your data analysis capabilities
by exploring Advanced Technologies
predictive modeling and data
visualization
familiarize yourself with business
intelligence tools and advanced
analytics platforms hands-on experience
take the lead on large projects and
handle critical business analysis
activities
mentor and support Junior analysts
provide them with guidance and
assistance remember the key is to
continue learning gaining practical
experience and staying up to date with
the industry trains good luck with your
business analysis Journey after that we
have lead business analyst the salary
range of a lead business analyst in
India can vary from 12 lakh per annum to
25 lakh per annum and in the US the
salary range for lead business analyst
is typically between 100 000 US dollar
to 150 000 US dollar next education and
Foundation take Advanced certification
and specialized training in leadership
and business strategy you should also
acquire domain knowledge become an
expert in your industry by staying up to
date on Trends regularizing on new
technologies
next analytical skills development is
very important develop expertise in
advanced analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn about
tools and Technologies for predictive
analysis and data-driven decision making
next we have business analysis
Technologies Master the art of
facilitating and negotiating in complex
stakeholders engagement
last hands-on experience take the lead
on strategic initiatives and large-scale
projects play a significant role in
shaping your organization's business
analysis processes and methodologies
everyone processes at their own pace
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demands keep seeking
professional development take on
challenging tasks and build strong
relationship with the industry to
accelerate your growth as a business
analyst who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who works
with companies to study their systems
services and products in order to
enhance present operation and come to
profitable judgments
a business analyst
evaluates the business model and how to
integrate it with technology to assist
organization in documented business
processes a business analyst is
responsible for processing and analyzing
the products and services to make
profitable decision to improve the
financial activities of the organization
business analysts handle all the
requirements demanded by the clients and
convey them to the product development
team now it's time to learn skills
required to become business analyst
analytical skills and critical thinking
great Achievers are great thinkers
the role of the business analyst comes
at the beginning of the software
development lifecycle a business analyst
must analyze the client requirements
effectively critical thinking helps the
analyst in examining different
situations and providing a solution
communication skill every role demands
communication skill but communication is
the key for every business analyst they
are supposed to have talked with
stakeholders a good business analyst
needs to have communication in different
phases be it with clients
product development team or the
implementation team for instance if a
product needs to be implemented then it
is the duty of a business analyst to
communicate with the clients regarding
requirement clearly otherwise the entire
project May collapse as a business
analyst facilitating meeting is very
important first point to boost your
confidence if you have good
communication skill database and SQL
SQL is an important skill that every
business analyst needs to understand a
database is a software to store the data
business analysts should have hands-on
experience on SQL from which they can
fetch data from these databases so it's
better to know MySQL Oracle DB no SQL or
mongodb
programming skills it's good to know
programming languages like python or r
business analysts have to deal with lots
of data that are beyond the limits using
spreadsheets so if you know Python
programming language it helps in
analyzing the data as well as we can
easily integrate it with SQL databases
to automate tasks
R also works in the same way R helps to
create interactive graphs and help in
analyzing the data
reports and dashboards business
dashboards are increasingly seen to help
business analysts to produce data in an
insightful way
dashboards are Consolidated with charts
and graphs on a single screen the
purpose of dashboard is to help business
analysts by allowing them to gather and
analyze the data let's say we have 10
sets of people working on a project we
have to maintain a dashboard in such a
way that it is understandable and
accessible to everyone so that everyone
can understand the growth of the project
these were some of the important skills
business analysts need to have
how to become a business analyst if you
are a fresher this is a very important
part
firstly it's essential to decide and
concentrate on the fundamentals of the
business analytics understanding the
fundamentals and choosing the right path
are crucial in every field start
learning the fundamentals of business
analytics first and start mastering it
pursue the related course it's a
reminder to you to have a look at the
business analyst master program link
which is given in the description box
below you can take up a business
management course and get certified to
become industry ready
internship an internship is a fantastic
way to learn more about a field or job
you might like to pursue internship in
business analytics will help you deal
with real-time experience working in
Industry this will automatically improve
your resume start taking up real-time
projects on Business Development and
Analytics lastly apply for a job
build a portfolio including your
practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary this used by
business analyst we have covered some of
the important tools frequently used by
business analyst based on its use
project management tool jira the
collaboration tools jira and Confluence
are very practical to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jira by
using platforms like jira all business
stakeholders May engage with various
teams and view the status of their
project
fellow is a project management platform
businesses use for teamwork and task
organization dividing the work into
columns on a board enables you to manage
your projects and effort dividing
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
help simplify and standardize your work
so for this purpose Trello is very
important tool
data visualization
the main use of data visualization tools
is the ability to quickly solve business
related problems Tableau is the prime
software for data visualization it
creates efficient visualization which
makes the stakeholders understand the
data more effectively
power bi is a software created by
Microsoft that meets your analytical and
business needs a visit allows access to
data even when using third-party
programs and services for instance you
can integrate it with SQL Server you can
enable python with power bi tool that
offers customizable visualization by
including data normalization and
purification the functionality of a
desktop program can be greatly increased
using power bi as we have already
learned reports and documentation is the
key skill for a business analyst to
create report and documentation we use
Google Docs Google Docs provide you with
templates for business research business
analyst may share and collaborate on
documents effectively using Google Docs
with the use of Google docs business
analyst can communicate with
stakeholders about any kind of file or
document
Microsoft PowerPoint as we previously
discussed good presentation skill is
always counted for a business analyst a
business analyst must have ability to
present project teachings to their
stakeholders so it's necessary to learn
Microsoft PowerPoint these were the
important tools for a business analyst
to manage their work now comes roles and
responsibility played by a business
analyst in Industry a business analyst
has a variety of roles and
responsibility therefore it is crucial
to understand thoroughly the roles and
responsibility held by business analyst
before learning how to become one
a business analyst pinpoints the goals
and issues of a company's business and
develops profitable Solutions
the assembled stakeholders and business
requirements they help in analyzing and
evaluating business processes an
organization has and identify the area
of improvement
business analysts collaborate with the
development team to create a plan for
addressing a specific issue they
aggressively offer feedback on the
design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that a company needs
business analysts evaluate companies
functional and non-functional
requirement different roles performed by
a business analyst are data analyst
business architect system architect and
product manager these are the roles
which are interdependent on a business
analyst in an organization so the top
companies hiring a business analyst
there are Accenture IBM Deloitte TCS
VMware McKinsey and Company we can also
include meta in this list this is the
job description provided by Accenture
for a business analyst role key
responsibility will include working with
clients and Technical Resources to
identify their business problem and
developing the analytical solution good
knowledge and understanding of digital
application
planning and managing business diagnosis
and planning activities understanding
and analyze functional impacts on front
to back application design and document
new process and system changes
performing interpreting requirement
analysis to identify value creation
opportunities for clients on average
Accenture offers 76
000 dollars per year for a business
analyst Rule now we will see job
description in IBM so what will be your
responsibility being a business analyst
in IBM be part of international teams in
the design build test run faces of
customer projects from various
Industries and interesting business
domains this role as its clients and
projects in implementation of wide range
of application and business processes
communication with business owners and
end user to Define business requirement
and with development team to ensure
delivery to the agreed standard and
quality support testing in the
resolution of Defense learn and apply
processes and methodologies related
latest it Trends from both the JD we can
understand that business analysts have
to deal with clients a lot
so on an average 84 000 dollars per year
is the salary offered for a business
analyst working in IBM
and the final part is salary of a
business analyst
the average salary of a business analyst
for refresher is seventy thousand
dollars per annum in USA and experienced
is one hundred thousand dollars per year
experience level you should be able to
evaluate and measure business Frameworks
and how they influence an organization
and their clients
coming to India the average salary of a
business analyst
for fresher ranges from 8 lakh per year
for experienced it can go as high as 15
lakhs per year and more also such as the
demand for business analyst all over the
world you are prepared to begin your
career in business analytics because you
have a better understanding of what
business analyst does their roles and
responsibility and steps involved to
become one postgraduate program business
analysis by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as business analysts
this program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
enhance their business analytics skills
and Advance their career in the field so
this program covers various topics such
as business analysts Essentials project
management data analysis data modeling
and data visualization
it also includes Hands-On training in
popular business analyst tools such as
you will see here such as Microsoft
Excel jira power bi and many others upon
completing the program Learners will
receive a certification from Simply
learn and the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst they will also have access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
overall the postgraduate program in
business analyst by simply learn is an
excellent option for individuals who
wants to enhance their business analysis
skills and Advance their career
perspective in this field so now next we
have business analytics boot camp I
simply learned this is an intensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business Analytics the program is
delivered online and is intended for
individuals who want to understand
business analysis comprehensively and
how it can be applied to real world
business problems this program covers
various topics such as data analysis
data modeling data visualization and
predictive modeling it also includes
Hands-On training in popular analysis
tools such as R python Excel and W the
business analytics bootcamp is designed
to provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in meaningful way it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insights and
recommendations to stakeholder
effectively upon completion of the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analyst role access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
now let's see more about the business
analyst Masters program this Masters
program I simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to
provide Learners with a deep
understanding or business analysis the
program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
advance their career prospectus in the
field of business analysis the program
covers various topics such as business
analysis Essentials project management
data analysis data modeling and data
visualization it also includes Hands-On
training in the popular business
analysis tools such as Microsoft Excel
Microsoft power bi I and python numpy
signed by the business analyst master
program is designed to provide Learners
with the skills and knowledge required
to succeed as a business analyst it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to effectively communicate with
stockholder manage projects and analyze
data upon completing the program
Learners will also get the certification
and the skills and knowledge required to
succeed in the business analysis role
which provides guidance and support to
help Learners transition into the job
market
the link will be in the description box
for all the courses next we have simply
learns business analytics for strategic
decision making certification program
which is designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business analysis and how it can be
applied in the real world business
problems the program is delivered online
as intended for individuals who want to
understand business analysts
comprehensively and Advance their career
this program is delivered by Indian
Institute of Technology roorkee this
program covers various topics such as
strategic analysis data modeling data
visualization predictive modeling and it
also includes Hands-On training in
popular analysis tools such as again
Microsoft Excel R and W
the business analysis for static
decision making certification program is
designed to provide Learners with the
skills and knowledge required to analyze
and interpret data create data models
and visualize data in a meaningful way
it also focuses on developing the
necessary skills to communicate insight
and recommendations to stack holder
effectively upon completing of the
program the learner will get the
certification by IIT roorkee and simply
learn they will also have the access to
Simply landscore Services which provides
guidance and support to help Learners
transition into the job market the link
will be in the description box for this
course also now we have simply learned
Sports graduate program in business
analytics in a comprehensive program
designed to provide Learners with a deep
understanding of business analytics the
program is delivered entirely online and
is intended for individuals who want to
advance their career in the field of
business analytics the program covers
the range of topics such as statical
analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data
so this program is sponsored by Purdue
University and you will get the
certification from IBM this program
covers a range of topics such as
technical analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data it also includes Hands-On training
in popular analysis tools such as
Microsoft Excel R programming Python and
tableau the postgraduate program in
business analyst is designed to provide
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst or data scientist it focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate insights and
recommendations to stockholders manage
projects and analyze large volume of
data upon completion of the program
Learners will receive a postgraduate
program in data analysis certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analytics or data sense rule
they will also have access to Simply
learns Career Services which provides
guidance and support to Learners
transition into the job market
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together I hope I made myself
clear with the agenda that said if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
post-graduate program and business
analytics from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below so what is project
management now as defined in pmi's pmbok
project management is application of
knowledge skills tools and techniques to
project activities to meet project
requirements so every project will have
an objective to accomplish similarly the
objective of project management is to
make the final deliverables in a finite
time and budget this involves having
clear understanding about the
deliverables of the project require
resources for the project resource in
terms of Human Resources Technical
Resources Financial Resources Etc
project manager should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
as constraints or aspects and manage
those throughout the Project Life Cycle
for which a project manager should have
a full view about a project and what is
that this project has to accomplish that
objective should be clear so as part of
project management the six constraints
which project manager should look at are
scope time quality cost risk and
resources so each of these areas has
very important role to play in project
management the clarity in scope the
clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incurs to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary one cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the scope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like Risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated for various
deliverables from the project so every
projects require resources resources may
be in terms of Human Resources Financial
Resources technology resources
environmental resources so all these
resources are used to produce the output
of the project so these resources has to
be managed with the sufficient
optimization and standardizations
required now let us understand the
definition of a project so what is a
project PMI defines a project as a
temporary Endeavor under taken to create
a unique product service or result the
temporary nature of a project indicates
that a project has a definite beginning
and end so when I say product unique
product it means every output it may be
similar products you are producing with
the same features and functionality but
the output of every project is unique
because it is unique in terms of all the
six constraints what we just discussed
now now when I say product it is very
easy for us to visualize it may be a
desktop it may be a laptop it may be a
car it may be a machine Etc but how do I
visualize a service a Project's output
is a service now it is it's about
building a capability a project by
through a project a capability can be
built to ensure Services can be provided
that's what the output of project is
service for example if I think about a
taxi services for providing a taxi
services I need a mobile app I need taxi
I need a server I need a data center so
all these are various different products
and services here service example can be
internet service so combination of all
the services and products builds the
capability for an organizations who can
provide the taxi services so building
that capability we say it is an output
of a particular project which is called
service similarly results can be
Improvement of something Improvement in
customer satisfaction increase in some
specific objectives or specific results
needs to be achieved in performance
perspective so output of every project
will be unique product or a service or a
result this we need to clearly
understand so when we say there is a
definite beginning and end every project
starts at a certain point in time and
ends at certain point in time so it has
a definite beginning and end that is the
reason it is temporary in nature it is
not an ongoing business activity right
so every project will have a life cycle
a beginning and end so when it starts
till end until the result or service or
a product which comes as an output of a
project project lifecycle is not ended
so interestingly in a product life cycle
or in a service life cycle you come
across many project life cycles so one
Project Life Cycle means one project is
initiated to introduce a product or
Services next project or initiated would
be to enhance the capability of a
service or a product next project
initiated after some time is to optimize
something similarly at the end of the
product lifecycle project is initiated
to return that product or services so in
a given product life cycle there may be
multiple Project Life Cycle so what is
involved in the Project Life Cycle it
involves five areas five groups we can
call it as so initiation planning
execution monitoring and closure so when
I say initiation it's up all about
understanding what is Project giving the
basic understanding of the project
collating the details and having key
stakeholders identified once that is
done one will move towards planning so
here in the initiation it is very
clearly one has to understand is Project
is worthwhile of doing so one has to
check the feasibility one has to measure
that particular investment is making
sense and then confirm yes it makes
sense to invest now next planning as we
have a basic understanding of yes this
project has to be done and a discussion
with the key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you're going in a
project in a agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
iteration you may go deep dive into
detail planning if it is a agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear Insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that a
clear blueprint of an project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the Project Life Cycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project execute in a sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure resource
you ensure right resources are required
if it is human resource one has to
educate the human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what they should have is
acquired by those individuals so that
deliverables can happen and they needs
to be managed the entire team needs to
be managed for that a clear structure
has to be created similarly when you do
technology resource perspective those
components has to be tested configured
then integrated again tested for
unchecked the performances so Collective
action of this results in a deliverable
during the execution so as the
deliverables are happening in the
execution it is quite obvious project
manager has to monitor review control
that particular deliverable and also the
processes tools resources used during
the project even those needs to be
monitored so that they are complaining
to the defined processes so during
monitoring there may be a deviation one
can found during monitoring there may be
the project is running the way it is
required so in this monitoring phase it
involves an action from project manager
to Monitor and control the work of the
project so comparing with the blueprint
of plan what is accomplished what is
created during the planning phase of
this project and as the execution
happens monitoring and control is
monitoring it and checking is that at
activities what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of your projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project deliverable
system accomplished within the cost what
is budgeted for the project so during
the project your project manager may
find there are certain deviations which
are occurred there are additional
challenges which has come in so for this
reason one has to ensure continued
monitoring as the execution happens and
identify those deviation and ensure
Whenever there is a deviation there is a
correction Whenever there is an
additional things coming in that needs
to be considered carefully whether that
need to be involved as part of this
deliverable or should be taken it
separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stake holders
of the project during the entire Project
Life Cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify so may
require to have a change in the
blueprint Itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand in
hand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process or constructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it is
very important and project is done
within the scope schedule and time and
the quality metrics defined then as the
completion of the project happens as the
monitoring and control says yes
deliverable has happened according to
the requirement then the project moves
to the closure the closure may be
closure of a specific project phase a
milestone deliverable or a phrasal
deliverable or it can be a deliverable
at the end of the project which is the
ultimate deliverable so processes in
closing has to be triggered Whenever
there is end of the phase Whenever there
is a deliverable to conclude and also at
the end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is defined what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or the next phase
or to the next project and at the same
time a sign off has to be obtained
formally and everything should be
summarized and have a good handshake
with the project stakeholder mainly a
business or customer and also
disseminating of Team means you will
dismantle the entire team and send them
back to their specific units or
specialization and they may get assigned
to new project or if it is a functional
they can go back to their functions to
do their functional activities so that
was about entire Project Life Cycle what
happens now while doing this I mentioned
there are six constraints that is scope
schedule fuel cost quality risk and
resources so keeping these in mind one
has to ensure project is successful in
all aspects so to become successful
there are few key areas which has to be
looked at so first six key areas are
scope schedule cost quality resources
and stakeholders now let us look at the
scope what the scope means scope is
about what needs to be delivered what is
in scope what is out of the scope so
this refers to all those deliverable
scope all those activity scope basically
we speak about two things one is product
scope and project scope product scope is
all about ensuring the features
functionality of products are well
defined and understood and signed off
and while delivering that product that
is tested against those defined features
and functionalities whereas projects go
focus on all the activities needs to be
done all those templates which has to be
used all the process which has to be
complied with all that skills which is
required to be applied so it is going as
defined so by doing this activities
which is defined as part of project
scope the result the deliverable will
come out which will be in line with the
deliverables features and functionality
which is defined as part of product
scope it is very important to ensure
entire projects happens within this
particular scope there should not be any
deviations from this schedule
perspective for that specifications what
we have defined for a product and a
project so these needs to be done in a
specific point in time means in a
specific schedule there will be start
time and time right so one has to plan
how long a project would take and what
are the deliverables should happen in
what sequence what activities are
required to accomplish this so all this
needs to be understood so while
performing the schedule management one
has to look at a specific deliverable at
a specific point in time by applying a
specific set of activities required so
this will tell you the duration of the
project this will provide you the
sequence of project this will also help
you to understand the dependency between
one task to another task this will also
help you to understand how the
deliverables happening in what sequence
which helps in prioritizing your
deliverables third is cost so as we know
to do any project it is very essential
to ensure project happens within that
budget so project cost is estimated
initially then that estimated cost will
be checked checked in terms of is the
assumptions considerations are right or
wrong is that really so much of a
monetary resources are required for the
project and then after understanding the
justification and obtaining the clarity
budget is I mean monetary resources are
allocated and confirmed approved then it
will become a budget that will be a cost
Baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost
now quality as we know quality is a very
important area which ensures the project
is delivered in time with all the
specifications defined by using all the
methods means by following all the
processes work instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same steps to the activity
so what quality management focus is to
ensure the intended objectives of a
projects are achieved already there is a
definition done in terms of various
different practices or processes needs
to be followed similarly specification
of each of the products are defined and
from that there should not be any
deviation so quality management should
focus on ensuring those activities are
done as defined those deliverables are
done according to the specifications
what is different it is very important
that way so for that there is a layer of
quality management should be a layer of
quality management where auditing our
control activities are initiated
periodically so that any deviations can
be seen easily and remember a project
manager can become cannot become part of
quality management like project manager
cannot audit project manager should have
a team or take the help of a team who
can able to do mostly the one which is
who is not part of the project is always
better resources now as I mentioned
earlier every project need resources it
may be human resources it may be
technology resources it may be any other
resources which are required to do the
project so organization acquires
resources configured and then deployed
for example in a project you acquire a
server you configure a server you deploy
a server technology resource human
resource is onboarded recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
cleared to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in a
project in the best possible manner so
interestingly when I say human resource
always there is a possibility that a
conflict can occur so when I say
conflict conflict of interest may be in
terms of what the individuals has to do
conflict in terms of the preferences in
terms of solutions what they are looking
at conflict in terms of using resources
different opinions different preferences
various reasons conflict and come across
so it is very important to project
manager to understand this dynamics of
human resources and manage this
conflicts project manager cannot shy
away from handling conflicts project
manager has to hone and resolve those
conflicts in the favor of project not in
the favor of any individuals so there
are various techniques to look at
resolving conflicts so that is like
compromising problem solving smoothening
accommodating
so whichever helps for that project
scenario for the project object is that
needs to be applied that technique has
to be taken up so here the resolution is
not at the specific individual's
preference it is with the objective for
their projects as any impact what kind
of impact positive or negative if it is
negative no that's not the direction the
direction should be ensuring project
gets that value through this conflict
resolution so project manager should own
it it's an accountability of a project
manager then as the human resources are
acquired there are five stages Team
Dynamics are involved so one has to
bring them then educate them about a
project as a education on the project
happens one has to go and do the job on
floor that needs to be observed means
one has to manage by looking at it and
any corrections is dividend that needs
to be guided so it is very Dynamic thing
when it comes to Human Resources
similarly in technology resources
standardization there is no ambiguity as
such but try right Resources with the
right configurations should be acquired
that is very important the next
stakeholders so who can be stakeholders
every project will have a stakeholder
who are internal and external to the
project so the internal stakeholders are
those who are part of the project who
are part of the organization who are
part of the customer organization or
part of supplier organization a
competition to my business means my
organization's business all this we can
call it as a stakeholders now every
stakeholders will have a specific
interest a power an ability to influence
now through their position through their
distance from the project they will get
impacted at the same time they will also
impact the project similarly they
influence and they get influenced
because of the project so a project
manager should identify all the
stakeholders and understand this what is
the kind of stakeholder is this in terms
of power in terms of legitimacy in terms
of influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be a
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am I going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get that inputs required through review
or periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up-to-date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
Focus areas to mention is communication
risk procurement critical success
factors deliverables and work breakdown
so this list is not exhaustive as we
deep dive into project I think you can
just keep listing the key Focus areas
more than this but whatever we have
indicated are the minimum which needs to
be looked at so when I say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any sense there should be a
receiver and there should be an
acknowledgment from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication how frequently we should
do that interactions or Communications
in intent of that particular
communication what is the expected
action or response from that
communication all this needs to be very
very clear and this can be articulated
it has to be articulated so one it is
articulated once there is a picture in
terms of what kind of communication has
to happen it is quite obvious there
should not be any deviation from the
agreed Communications requirements and
whenever there is a need of change to
the communication requirements from the
stakeholders that needs to be updated
for this one established stakeholders
identified so stakeholder management and
communication are very closely linked
and Associated a engagement with the
stakeholder will become successful with
an effective communication approaches
next is risk so every project which is
undertaken by organization that will
have certain amount of risk which
organization will evaluate similarly
within the Project Life Cycle lot of
risk comes up which would have certain
impact to the project now risk refers to
by definition an uncertain event it has
an uncertainty an event which is
uncertain and when it occurs it will
have an impact on the project positively
or negatively now current scenario in
everywhere the projects What You observe
closely people tend to look at the risk
which are threats that is negative only
but they fail to recognize the risks
which are opportunities the positive
risks so another gap which we see when
do the risk management is that is done
in the initial phase of the project as
the project is kicked off someone will
do the risk assessment have a list of
risk identified but unfortunately there
is no categorizations for that risk and
how is that going to impact the project
that is not clear thirdly risk
management or list of risk are created
only once it is not done repeatedly so
risk identification and Analysis and
assessment of that risk has to be done
throughout the life cycle of your
project reason being the risk which
looks as in high impact when project is
initiated as the project progresses the
impact levels will vary Maybe the middle
of the project the impact may be very
high or low so likewise the impacts of
the risk will vary throughout the
Project Life Cycle it may be positive it
may be negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the Project Life
Cycle as I said that is also a dynamic I
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and I keep it as it is I need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and Analysis should also be
done regularly periodically so that one
will have a clear understanding about is
that risk still valid is that risk is
there still or not what is the level of
variations in terms of impact of the
risks so this Clarity will be there so
that neces organization or project
manager can get ready to face those
risks if it is a negative risk
definitely you should have a mitigation
or avoidance or acceptance whatever the
mitigation plan you have to eliminate
the negative impact of the risk when it
occurs okay if it is a positive risk
it's quite obvious one has to take the
advantage of that one has to enhance
exploit share a positive risk so that
organization is benefited further
procurement so whenever a project is
initiated whenever a project is taken up
the organization who is doing the
project cannot create everything cannot
develop everything in that Project Life
Cycle so organization would take a
decision make a decision stating that
some of the deliverables we make
ourselves some of the products we make
ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a specific supplier you
cannot go with every supplier you should
evaluate those suppliers qualify the
suppliers and then select onboard the
supplier and then get the services or
products supplied by that particular
supplier so while doing this one has to
understand what type of Contracting they
need to enter with so three types of
contracts we speak basically one is
about Cost Plus contract where cost is
fully known to the project manager and
to the organization so upon are from
known cost Fe will be paid to the
supplier another one is fixed price
where project manager or the
organization who is awarding that
contract to A supplier will not know
what is the cost instead it is a fixed
price but important here is the scope of
work needs to be clearly articulated and
defined another type of Contracting can
be time and material where the billing
will happen based on the amount of time
one is spent on that particular a higher
resource or onboard resource and
retirement material basis and what is
that effort that resource has been put
based on the building will happen so
three types of contracts depending on
the different scenarios of the project
will be signed with the contractor
however before doing that it is very
essential to identify those suppliers
sign off with them and monitor and
manage them so if deliverables are not
there it is very essential to look at
the termination who has to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
terminating should be able to put some
effort to educate them also so that they
come up to the mark So project is
benefit so depending on what needs to be
done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor So based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved its objectives
our project has not achieved his
objectives so key is a critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if you want to
become successful in an exam critical
success factor is scoring or passing the
examination or let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60 and above so critical success
factor for me to get promoted is to pass
in this particular exam so to pass in
this exam minimum I should score is 60
percent that is kpi passing in the exam
that is critical success factor so how
will I measure that success factor is
kpi so every project which it produces
uses a specific product or Services by
using a specific resources and each of
these the resources the processes the
templates the deliverables all these
needs to be measured on a continual
basis so there are critical success
factors defined and those are measured
by defining kpis to the critical success
factors so basically critical success
factor provides the Insight towards what
needs to be measured and when you
measure what should be the focus and to
achieve those critical success factors
the indicator is key performance
indicators when you measure yes the
moment you achieve that your CSF is
achieved next deliverables so
deliverables are those which comes as an
output of the project right it may be a
product it may be a service it may be a
result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables may
be the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have it defined scope will have a
defined specification so those
derivatables has to be measured tested
and one has to confirm yes this
deliverable is performing as we are
intended to have the performance
accordingly the decision will happen
should we accept this particular
deliverable or not if there any
deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focus on
the product straight whether it has
achieved that results or not is that
functional as needed or not one has to
ensure these deliverables has all those
features and functionalities only then
that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when I
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture I
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if I say a car so
I can think of a body external I can
think of a mirror on that body I can
think of a glass in the front side as
well as the back side and also I can
think of Interiors like seat then
accelerator steering dashboard only
second visualize but since I'm not a
technology expert relating to car can I
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like
engine the battery assembly I don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or Services should be broken down into
multiple pieces I'm not saying go and
break that product I am saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if I say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever you visualize body body
structure mirror mirror assembly
headlights then tires so likewise
whatever I can visualize I will make it
as a line items under the the exterior
so under for example under a mirror
mirror I can speak about mirror glass
mirror cap mirror pedestal and mirror
assembly where it moves where you can
move the mirror so these are the various
components involved in a mirror so I
need to ensure by breaking down the
product into multiple levels but depos
decomposing it to multiple levels I can
able to visualize the product very
clearly what is there in detail so once
I have the details I will articulate
those what is that particular work
breakdown element is product breakdown
element is then I will look at what
skills and capabilities required for
that product and I will assign the
resources accordingly so once activities
resources everything is assigned
automatically this will become our
breakdown structure further after
creating our breakdown structure one
will go on sequence activity look at
sequencing will happen based on in what
priority deliverable should happen What
order deliverable should happen then
once the sequencing is done it will be
checked to see whether anything can be
be optimized anything can be done in
such a way that smooth flow of the
project can happen there is no
dependencies which will make project to
delay like as the flow happens smoothly
so you would find the various techniques
like critical path method Network
diagramming critical chain method so all
these are used the floats of an
activities are checked then leads and
lags of the activities the relationship
between the activities so accordingly
full visualization in terms of how the
project will flow and how in what order
the deliverables are happening can be
easily visualized so that is the reason
first activity is to do the product
breakdown which would result in work
background structure so those are the
points till now whatever I mentioned are
the basic understanding one should have
about a project and project management
so as you deep dive into various best
practices like PMP by P PMI Prince 2 by
X loss scrum Mass result scrum Master
similarly you have certified scrum
master so many agile practices so when
you look at any of the best practices
that will tell you clearly articulate
what should be the practice for you to
adopt and adapt that practices so that
your project can become successful so
any of those approach you touch upon all
those refers to these basic things in
the absence of these basic things none
of those best practices discusses the
project management now typically in the
industry there are a lot of job roles to
the project management which we have
seen so based on that this information
is captured here on various job rules in
a project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager Project Lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member so not
necessarily all the project management
roles are limited to this so these are
the roles which commonly you see and we
are trying to capture that to give the
Insight right when I say project manager
the project manager is the owner one has
to take an accountability for the
project right so project managers takes
the project according to the plan and
plays a lead role in all the steps of
the project management right so
responsibility should be managing
reviewing and prioritizing the task
wherever necessary looking after risk
management stakeholder management and
project communication management some of
the salary what we found while we were
doing the survey the success ratio of a
project depends majorly on the project
manager so the demand for project
manager is rapidly increasing in the
market so accordingly uh 75
000 474 per year that is USD in INR it
is fifteen hundred thousand so this is
what the salary of an approximation what
was found next role we look at senior
project manager where where senior
project manager is ahead of the overall
project management plan the role demands
in-depth knowledge of all the project
aspects on a specific on the specifics
of the project the responsibilities
would be planning and coordinating
complex projects visiting project sites
to check progress and handle complex
issues so salary
looks like one not four thousand dollars
per year here twenty ninety two thousand
INR per year so the role of senior
project manager is one of the highest
paying roles in the industry as we have
seen having several allowances and
bonuses because of the criticality
involved in that project and the
accountability level of that particular
individuals in the organization next
role Project Lead so project leads are
the one who leads the people throughout
the project and provide them with all
the information required throughout so
responsibilities involve motivating the
team beneath taking care of their needs
and paying attention to what they feel
ordering or controlling the project team
since the project lead has more freedom
than the project manager salary Project
Lead makes sure that project gives the
best possible outcome and is hence the
demand for the project lead in the
company never reduces so in USD 82 000
per year whereas in INR it is one
million 269 000 per year next roll I
will look at on resource man manager so
resource manager is the human resource
needed to make the project success right
so one has to manage those resources
responsibility involved assigning the
right people to the right projects at
the right time managing employees
currently and determining hiring needs
depending on the Project's requirements
so salary would be around 64 000 USD
which comes around 966 794 in INR
project management office analyst for
this role the project management office
analyst works with pmo means project
management office and does not look at
the project or manage the project
directly instead does most of the data
driven work which required for a project
to have or project to get supported by
that so that project managers will have
better Insight analyzing and
interpreting the data concerning the
project figuring out the future risks to
the project finding new ways to advance
the idea of the project management so
salary would be one or six thousand two
fifty three per year in USD whereas 449
9337 in INR per year so steering
committee member so the steering
committee members are the members who do
not work on the project themselves they
are there to help the project manager
like providing inputs during the
development of a project advising on the
budget and evaluating the project
strategies taking regular feedbacks on
the project managers and asking
necessary questions so salary would be
around 68 497 dollars per year so those
were the various rules and that is not
that list is not an exhaustive list
various different roles we come across
but these are the basic roles which is
seen in the industry these roles are
being recruited now there are various
project management certifications which
are offered as I mentioned earlier so
those certifications are PMP that is
project management professional from PMI
agile certified practitioner that is PMI
ACP again from PMI then certified
associate in project management so
difference between capm and PMP is like
capm would act as a basic level of
certification for those who does not
have a sufficient project experience
project management experience whereas
pmps for those was some project
management experience similarly PMI sap
is the one who is aspiring to look at
agility in project management and they
can go for it certified scrum Master yes
it is a scrum Master certificate which
will explain the role of a scrum master
in detail similarly prints to a
certification from axolos which also
speak about all the aspects of the
project what we discussed and provides
the framework for project management
excelos also provides Princeton
certification in agile also agile prints
to certification so we will look at each
one of this certain details which are
required for us to know so project
management professional as I mentioned
is most acknowledged and value the
certificate value what it carries which
has resulted to the certified
Professionals in landing up in highest
paid jobs in the world so certified
managers gets 20 percent more salary
than the average salary so to take up an
examination one has to go through the
formal training of 35 hours that is one
of the prerequisites and there should be
some experience of 4 500 hours of
project managing project by Leading
Rarities activities of a project and
once the person becomes eligible with
that prerequisites person will become
register in the pmi's website becomes
member and then go for examination so
examination fee for PMP would be 4.5
dollars for the members who are
registered with PMI and for those who
are not registered as a member with BMI
it is 555 the duration of the
examination is four hours and the number
of questions will be 200 which are
multiple choice questions so is each
questions carries one marks there is no
negative score now prerequisites one has
to have 4 500 hours directing and
leading the projects that experience has
to be filled in while filling the
application if a person is a the
bachelor degree holder and along with
the 35 contactors of PMI PM education
now prerequisites for the one who is not
a graduate who may be high school or
diplomo is 7 500 hours of directing and
leading projects 35 hours of PM
education so those are the prerequisites
before one will go on appear for
examination so once an individual passes
PMP examination that certificate is
valid for three years so now after three
years if the person aspires to keep the
certificate continued they need to
produce 60 pdus professional development
units which has to be acquired during
those three years how to acquire one has
to go through additional learning one
has to contribute towards project
management knowledge base so those needs
to be evidenced and then renewable fee
has to be paid and certificate has to be
renewed then agile certified
practitioner as we saw for PMP here
agile certified practitioner
demonstrates that one has relevant
experience in education to handle and
Lead agile project the organization has
started shifting towards agile as we
know in today's industry which makes
this certification fast growing in the
world so examination fee would be 435
dollars for PMI members 4.95 for non-pmi
members duration is three hours and
multiple choice questions 120 questions
prerequisites is 2 000 hours project
management experience with 1500 hours
agile experience and 21 contact hours of
agile practices so maintenance 30 videos
are required for every three years and
after paying the renewal fee that can be
renewed now certified associate in
project management so here this is an
entry level certificate of PMI
especially for those people who has less
project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project management so examination fee
would be dollar 25 for PMI members
whereas three hundred dollars for
non-members of BMI so duration of
examination is three and examination
will have 150 multiple choice questions
so prerequisites someone who has
secondary diploma 23 contact hours of PM
education is enough there is no
experience of doing the project is
required as we saw in PMP so maintenance
is again three years someone who need to
continue this certification has to
retake the examination every three years
next certified scrum master so certified
scrum Master is an entry level
certification that helps the
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most
sought-offed certifications as other
after this one can get the designation
of certified scrum Master which is
offered by scrum Alliance so examination
fee which will change team to time which
is not revealed so one has to approach
the training organization where they
will get trained on certified scrum
master so duration of examination is 60
minutes and pattern would be 16 hours 2
days of training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
stream then prerequisite is done for
maintaining these credentials so one has
to ensure it has renewed every two years
then projects in controlled environment
that is prints too so prince2 is a
method which is effective mostly from
the base of UK all the organizations who
are from UK region prefer prints to
certification and it is as popular as
any other project management
certifications like PMP so examination
fee would vary from 900 to thousand
dollars depending on where exactly
you're taking the examination and
certification will happen at two levels
one is at Foundation level and other one
is practitioner so in Foundation it is
60 Questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it is 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55 percent to
clear the examination so prerequisites
for Princeton Foundation is none where
as prince2 Foundation is a prerequisite
for Princeton practitioner examination
so to maintain the certificate one has
to achieve 20 cpts every year continued
professional development
what is jira
jira is an agile project management tool
used for project management bug tracking
issue tracking and automate workflow it
is also the solution that provide
Concepts and solution to the entire team
the clients allowing for collaborations
and transparency it is an incident
management tool and a platform
independent tool that can run on any
platform or operating system and also in
a multilingual tool
so now we will see how does Rita work
if we look into the work process of jira
then it permit us to organize the task
and other priorities constructing a
well-organized workflow in different
management
the workflow includes review and
approval steps and multiple resolutions
possibilities
going through this workflow we can
create a subtask customize us manage
activities set due dates reminders task
Recycling and determine what types of
project this helps gather contextual
data or information regarding the task
the track and the process report and
Tackle all the bugs and release it when
approved
after understanding how zero works we
will see its component along with its
uses
what is a component in terms of project
management
our projects of divisions are called
components these subdivisions are
applied to break down problems into
manageable chunks within a project which
later helps to generate good reports
that is collecting useful statistic and
grouping data contextually
as we know that jira components are very
helpful and most software project team
use these components and also big
companies might use jira components more
often to manage the details team because
larger data sets are more difficult to
track
the project manager put a lot of effort
behind to ensure no task is overlooked
and that reports are prepared for action
but as T Max pen
the project becomes more complicated
when it's become too easy for things to
slide through the cracks have issue and
have created problems
to overcome all these the team uses
Chira components to track issue software
bugs and individual work this jira
component helps to organize these issue
based on functionality features
customers and departments let's take a
look at another example let's take an
Uber is an example
Suppose there are three subcomponents of
projects a driver's app a customers app
and a food delivery app
and under your food delivery app project
you have got like order Meal special
offer and food Combos and so on how will
you track all this information across
different projects this is done by
components
next we will discuss jira concept
jira works on following three concepts
project issue and workflow
the first one is Project it is a
collection of issues you can use a jira
project with your team to coordinate and
improve the development of a product by
tracking the project managing the help
desk and more depending on the
requirements of your needs it can be
processed and configured according to
your and your team's need
and the second one is issue as we
already know jira is a tour used in
project management and also uses issue
to track all the tasks according to your
team and how your team uses jira the
issue can be represented as a project
the task user requirements detection of
software bugs and enhancement of the
project
the next one is workflow jira has
built-in workflows and it is used to
track the life cycle of an issue where
it tracks a set of status and
transformation that an issue moves
throughout the process and typically
represent a process within your
organization
and lastly let's take a look at features
of jira software
so the first one is Authentication
users are authenticated against the
active directory remember me provides
automatic login when the user visits jio
software
it helps in quick access to the software
the next one is dashboard
users can have more than one dashboard
on the main page showing Dynamic
information presented in text or
graphics
a team can share a dashboard to track
the progress
it helps an immediate access to
meaningful mattress that are used to
track the health of a project or
application and to manage resource
workloads
next is workflow
it defines a cycle of an issue with
validation first it will open then it
will go in progress
and it will resolve then it will close
if it is not resolved it will go to
reopen and to the progress
the next one is they can be shared by
several projects and can be unique
it can be simple and sometimes quite
complex too
the next one is issue searching
this will allow you to find an issue in
which you are interested
it gives better transference so that
everyone can see what is being done and
the progress that is being made
the next one is time tracking
this feature allows for the input and
monitoring of actual and estimate time
span on an activity
it will allow more effective management
of free sources and many more
next is Project Administration
they control the access to the data and
who can access it and what should be
accessed
they can also control who can view and
edit issue handle locally without system
administration involvement
and the last one is road maps
our roadmaps allow you to create a clear
version of the product you are
developing
and can use to find what needs to be
done and when problems are expected to
be fixed
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
email ID video unique name
there should be a site name
and you can provide any name and it
should be unique
or after writing any name suppose
it should be unique and just after that
you have to agree
so next page is this here jira will ask
you whether you are new to this or you
are experienced
suppose you are new to it
and your agile methodology is neutral
and suppose we spend our time on working
on features and it is flexible schedule
to finish up or not
so for our project we are going to use
scrum template so we will change the
template first
then this scrum
use template
and we'll use T manage
project because is it it's free let's
take a name for our project let's
suppose here
sample
and here Jiro also assign a key to your
project that is Js
this key can be used to refer you any
project so let's create the project
you're also having so many options for
integrating your jio experience with
other platform but uh let's for now
let's take
uh just skip this
here is a first thing we need to do is
first we will create an apic so let us
enable
yeah this is the Epic panel right
now over here at the left down you can
you can give it an epic name for this
project
um I wanted to use an example of
favorite
where I could store and view my products
so let us
it's the favorite
so now that we have created the Epic we
can I can use this drop down menu to
view the details
so first view all details
let it make a little big
okay over here you can add a description
you can also add comments
and we can add stories
so let us see how to do that at first
you can click add
to add a collection
sorry
if you click add a child issue
so here you can
specify what kind of issue you want to
create like any story task or Burger Etc
so for first story let us see that we
want to save our products so in our
favorite list so we want to write here
product and we will create it right let
us also add another story for sharing
the favorite so
so here
favorite
and then we will create it
so now we have created our two stories
now we will close this section and we
can view our stories in the background
next step is to create a Sprint
so
very simple all we have to do is to
track
this backlog
and the next one
yeah we have to
start sprinting
and it will ask you for the detail over
here and you can see a Sprint name
and the duration date timing and Etc
so just
add it
so now we have created a toast print and
you can see to do in progress to do in
progress and done in the board section
so now you can open up the stories and
few
and view the details inside
you can assign to the same one and you
can do it at a set story Point estimate
is a quantitative value of how much
relevance a story has in the Epic so far
now let us just set it as
four
or three
and over here
you add a child issue
since a story is about saving the
product and the favorite so
first
you can first create a favor button on
the product page
page that is product page right so page
[Music]
you can also add another task to create
a new database so that we can store the
product that we like or like
create
foreign
product
now that we all are done here we can
close this section story
here we will do the same thing for this
story also
detail is over here
or is it three
you can add a child issue button over
here and we can create
page to display
spray
favorite
[Music]
and our second subtask could be about
creating a button so that we can view
our favorite list like we can add
View
favorite button
okay where we are done here we can also
see this
so now you can see the studio button
over here and now for our sub task so
you can expand them and you can click on
the progress
now see that the since the story in
progress we can close this
slide over
sorry into in the process
we can do this to the same for the
Second Story
we'll open this
return
in progress
close it will shift it to in progress
now once you are done with the subtask
you can go to the same place and you can
specify it
as done
this also
so you can fill it down
now you can see that the progress is 100
percent
100 done right so now you can cast the
story
and shifted it over
the done column
you can do same for the next
so now once we completed all the sub
tasks and the stories you can go in the
complete and you have to complete the
spend
yeah
we have also seen how to assign it to
someone
and how to create story points estimate
and how to track progress of a project
and now we will see how to manage
workflow so the first thing you need to
do to access your workflow is first you
have to go to the port and to the right
corner button
and click on the manage workflow over
here you can see the face that your
business is currently going through and
start creative to in progress
Etc so you can also add a few face like
if you want to add let us know add
another to-do status
suppose add
so once you are done over here it will
come you can see
the
face that you have deployed and you have
to update your workflow and save and
continue
so you can exit this interface and you
have the overhead to the board
in our way you can see
that
the add face for your project
so now that we have seen what overflow
repeat so now that we have seen what
workflows are let us explore few other
options
so the first thing that we can see is
code
over here you can integrate jira with
other platforms
so that you can manage any of your
project easily and you can also have an
in-house inversion interface let's
embark on this transformative adventure
together I hope I made myself clear with
the agenda that said if you are an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
your prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
post-graduate program and business
analytics from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below important part of
jira configuration these are a
collection of configured values to be
later used by one or more jira project
there are seven types of schemas
including notification schemes
permission scheme issue type schemes Etc
comes the last question in the list what
does jira schema consist of to answer
this question the jira schema is consist
of notifications workflows issue types
permissions screens and field
configuration in this session we will
start with certain exercises which we
will perform in Tableau in order to
understand some basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns so by importing this
data into Tableau first of all we will
create relationships between these
sheets in order to identify who all have
placed orders and how many people have
returned the orders we will do some
analysis on the orders placed by certain
set of people and Order returned by
certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people's table between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
open
so see the region and the person these
two columns from the people table have
now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
all right
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the orders
table
and then you have the people uh sheet in
which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who's the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet
and then in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not inner join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the
order ID
okay so just edit this
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left join mean
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the return statement which
have data means which are returned
otherwise show null for the order IDs
which are not returned so if you see
this is the these are the two columns
from the return statement and these are
null because this is relevant to the
order IDs which are not returned okay
which has been accepted by the customer
but these are the orders for which you
see data in the returned and Order ID
column it means that these have been
returned
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet 1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rose
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or the super State per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
now
sought by highest to lowest
so California is giving me the maximum
profit of 76 381 then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
whatever
so out of 120 out of the total orders of
127 okay so this is the number of total
number of orders which have been
returned for California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a
cancers there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
table to refresh his orders and identify
new rows using order deal so as and when
new data is being added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of orders
which have been returned by all the
customers the distinct count of order
IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated field to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left join with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers so what we
have to do is we have to click right
click on the customer name and click
create set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer we have to now create a
calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
foreign
that per customer we are using a level
of definition function include which
means that per customer what is my
average sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here
and name is as name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
yeah
else it is called as
emerging state
okay so we have now
three calculated Fields average sales
per customer emerging or developing
State and sales goals
now we will use this in our reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
okay so if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing State on the
color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is
19511 okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
foreign
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will group from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
hello and welcome to this new session on
tableau
now in this session we will talk about
how to prepare dashboards and how to
Interlink reports within the dashboard
so in order to start this session we
will first create couple of reports and
then include them in the dashboard and
then link them together
so for this session
as usual we are using the sample
Superstore data set for our example
now first we will create a report where
we are gonna
show profit by region per region
so first we will drag the region
in the rows column and we will get all
the regions
and
state
so we have all the states per region in
our report now and then we will drag
sales
and profit
so now we have our sales and profit
measures the column level
now just also drag now the region to the
color section so now we have each region
colored
the entire sales and profit per region
is distinguished by the different colors
Central is south and west
now
click on the
colors
now we want to show the labels using the
marks card okay so we want to show the
region
okay so we need to include the show the
marks labels just a second
so enable the labels
say show Mark labels
okay
so you have on the left this is the
profit and this is the total sales now
rename
this sheet as region and state analysis
report
okay
now let's create another worksheet
now in this sheet just drag the state
on the
marks card now automatically Tableau
will detect that you know you have
dropped a particular State and we have
the states of United States so it has
identified the state names and showed
you the identifiers of the states on the
map and automatically
identified the latitude and longitudes
which are generated by Tableau and
giving you the markers on each and every
state
now drag the sales measure to the color
panel
okay so now this is sales per state in
the color scheme with the color scheming
then now Drag The Profit to the size
so now each state you have the color the
the profit and the sales
now you can edit the colors and you can
select
a particular scheme of colors and say
apply and okay so now you are able to
distinguish
the colors on the state
now after this
just rename the sheet as
profit by state
report
now create let's create another report
now in this report drag the subcategory
to the column section
and
sales and profit measures in the
rows
okay
now click on the right click on the sum
profit pill and check dual access
now click right click on the profit
access and say synchronize access
now select some sales from the card
marks card and change the notation as
bar
and for profit change the notation as
line
so now this is a fair display of
sub category wise
sales and profit representation that
these are the sales and what is the
profit
now go to the marks all marks and drag
the category section
the
category section as the tooltip
okay so for each and every bar or line
item you should now see the category
also
save your report
and rename this now report as sales
by and profit by sub category report
now let's create a new dashboard
now the reports which we have just now
created first our dashboard size let's
make it as automatic
okay then
let's show the dashboard title click
click on the dashboard title
now drag the reports which you have
created
profit by state
sales and sub category report
and region and
okay so you have all your three reports
in a single dashboard now
profit by state sales and profit by sub
category and region by and state
analysis report now we will link these
reports so go to dashboard
click on actions
add an action called new filter
select Source sheet in the source sheet
dashboard 2
only select region and state analysis
report
and in the Target sheet just deselect
region and state analysis
on the source sheet keep the Run action
on select and
click
ok
now whatever state you select over here
that particular state will be used as a
filter across both these reports so it
means in North Dakota you have all these
category subcategories being sold and
their Associated profit and on the map
profit by Straight report you can see
the North Dakota State being highlighted
or only selected and the relevant profit
and sales
okay so here is the total profit and
sales in the profit by state report and
in this sales and profit by sub category
report you have the breakup of the
profit and sales across the categories
similarly you can select any other state
and automatically the
filters will get applied automatically
see this Marine Main
okay
so with this we cover our example of how
to create multiple reports and then
connect them
or encapsulate them in a single
dashboard for a single view across all
these reports we are going to take
example of the Netflix database which we
have and we'll prepare certain reports
in order to identify what kind of
reports we can generate from such a data
set
So currently on my screen what you can
see is the Tableau the Netflix data
sheets the data sources where you have
the Netflix shows movies their
Associated duration uh what kind of
shows or movies are there the release
here are the associated rating
description and a key which is the show
ID now this is the unique identifier for
each show
in this Netflix title sheet and with
this show ID all other sheets are
related like you know who are the
directors of the show in which country
the show was released
what is the cost of each show all that
information is in this sheet and to
which particular category basically the
listed in category is being uh listed in
this particular sheets so what we're
going to do is first we are going to
import this sheet into tableau
okay and then create relationship
between them using the Tableau
relationship canvas so first our the
primary transaction table the sheet in
which all the information related to
movies is there or shows is there is in
Netflix titles and then we will drag
sheet like Netflix cast titles cast now
Tableau has automatically identified the
relationship between the show ID of
titles and show ID of titles cast and it
has made a join
so if you double click this
you can see this relationship
cardinality and the related fields
similarly I'll drag release titles
category countries and directors
Now by virtue of this all the sheets
have now been joined with Netflix titles
and with this relationship ready we can
start preparing our reports
now let's create a basic report where we
can just glance the data like you know
whatever we were seeing in the Excel how
it looks in w
so you have all the types of movies then
for example I drag the release Here
now first I do not want to consider it
as a
Dimension so I'll just
release here or category per type there
is a release Here
and then I'll drop the listed in
so now these are the categories so per
year the the details of the categories
right and then you can
drag the title and the associated rating
so this is just a view of your data
we can name it as shows listing report
now let's try to create some report for
some
measures some numbers
Etc
so now let's check in which country how
many movies or titles were released you
know what is the count
so first let's drag the
country
so as soon as we drag the country
uh
field it is identified that it has the
geographical names and identified the
latitude and longitude details so
Tableau internally does that
automatically and it has identified the
spots across the globe of the relevant
country
now let's drag the listed in on the
color section
now what it is doing is it is showing in
which country what different kind of
uh category wise movies are or shows
have been released like in Sri Lanka
documentaries have been released in
India action and adventure United States
action and adventure like this
now let's
put
a count of
the titles right so if you see 247
action and adventure movies or shows
have been released in United States
okay so this is one inference by this
particular report you can
identify
so let's see this report as
listed
in
by country
okay now let's create another report
we will call it as the per year
statistical report in this first I'll
put the release ears in the column
now
count of Netflix titles so this is the
count of Netflix titles per year so 2017
2016 14. and then count of Netflix
titles in the countries
this is the second bar chart okay now
what I'll do is I'll combine it into one
so one report
we are
moving in the bar creating the bar and
one in the line now I just have to
so we will click on the count of Netflix
titles by country right click Market
dual access so now as soon as you click
click this both the uh charts have been
combined and right click over here and
say synchronize access
okay
okay so now if you can see see right in
2017 you had uh 2 303 Netflix releases
across all categories and 1159
titles right one zero six three titles
in 2017 so this is a descending
representation of the count of titles
released per year across category and
across titles
so let's call this as
per year
stats
now let's create another report
number of shows
per title okay
so or or sorry per rating so we will
drag the rating column
and
we will
count of titles
and
unique count of titles and unique count
of show IDs
okay
one is bar and one is line
so this is a report which shows rating
wise titles and the show IDs
so in the tooltip you can see the
listing count of titles and show ID per
rating
okay so let's call it
shows per rating
now let's create another sheet
call it as
shows
by cast
so in this
what we're going to do is first drag the
cast column on the rows section you have
name all of all the cast and then we
drag the
show ID on the column section and put a
count D and sort it okay
you can remove the null cast and this is
your
sorted order and on the labels section
you can say show Mark labels and you
will see the count where Donald pump K
here has done the maximum
so this is the details on this sorted
order that who has done how many shows
okay
then next is
shows by director similar to shows by
cast
dragged
director into rows
or differently if you want to prepare
into columns and then count off
show ID
okay sort it
and you can actually filter out the null
director value
and this is the account put the label
so you can see Jan's Twitter has the
maximum shows
okay
then create another report
shows by category
now similarly drag the listed in
in the rows and show ID count
remove the null category
and sort
labels show Mark labels so International
movies are the highest category dramas
the next comedy International TV shows
this way
you have your category
now let's create a dashboard in which we
want to bring combine all these reports
and
take a common view so first let's drag
listed in by country
then
shows by director
also please let's set the size as
automatic
then let's drag shows by category
and shows by cast
now these four reports are on a single
dashboard we will link them to each
other so go to worksheet actions
add action
filter
select dashboard one
only select shows by category here
and in Target dashboard one
except shows by category keep everything
else
and in the source sheet just select
click select
click ok
okay now whatever category you will
select over here
that related category data will
automatically be shown in other reports
like see International movies across the
globe across countries directors of only
International movies who has done the
maximum
Johnny Tow and shows by cast right that
who has done the maximum International
movies or dramas
or comedies
travel has a maximum number of comedies
and then if you see the comedy movies uh
you know these are the count of comedy
movies released across the countries and
the who is the director
another a very interesting report which
you can prepare is that for example you
want to check in which country maximum
duration of uh your
maximum duration of
movies have been released so
first let's create a measure
and remove this
okay
so if you see
maximum duration of the movies or the
entire Netflix content is maximum United
States then in India these many minutes
next is United Kingdom and you can also
change the colors
whatever you feel is as per your
standards or as per the convention you
can change the color combination
so there are multiple ways you can
generate reports and uh hope you have
understood how you can leverage such a
data to create your reports let's embark
on this transformative adventure
together I hope I made myself clear with
the agenda that said if you are an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply launch
postgraduate program and business
analytics from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below also if you are
already a business analyst and want to
upgrade your skills to become a
successful data scientist with proper
training and certification from the
experts and reputed universities then
Caltech data science bootcamp should be
the right choice for more details use
the link in the description box below
today we are going to talk about power
bi what are its features what are the
basic advantages of using a visual
civilization 2 like power bi and we will
talk about how to install powerbo bi and
other features it provides and the basic
setup
so let's discuss what's in it for us
today
now we will first talk about why power
bi you know why it's a popular tool and
what problem it solves what is power bi
and what are the primary features of
power VI which you can use in your
day-to-day data analytics visualizations
creating fancy reports creating
meaningful intelligent reports
for your organization for your personal
use for crunching numbers for generating
reports real time Etc
now the most popular tool for power bi
is the power bi desktop uh I'll show you
certain uh aspects of power bi desktop
and then I'll show you the steps how to
install power bi desktop on your machine
and then definitely power bi desktop is
a free tool provided by Microsoft but
then you can also subscribe for an
Enterprise version which is primarily
used by Enterprises for publishing their
data so we'll see the difference and
then overview of our dashboards which
can be created uh you know what kind of
dashboards can be created in power pi
so this is the agenda for us today
now why power bi so generally uh you
know visualization tools reporting tools
are required in order to create and
prepare and analyze meaningful data it
could be a data for an organization it
could be a social media platform data it
could be a data from iot devices but
something which needs to be analyzed and
some intelligent inferences and data
mining has to be done on top of it now
imagine there is today we are in a world
where terabytes of data and information
is getting generated on an instantaneous
basis on minute-by-minute basis so it
becomes very essential to churn out
something meaningful something
intelligent out of it in the market
there are a lot of other tools which are
available like clicks uh all tricks
Tableau and power bi so power bi is a
Microsoft product which is one of the
most popular products and it comes as a
free to download product Microsoft power
bi desktop which is available and I'll
show you a couple of ways how you can
install it on your machine but why power
bi is uh popular is because it provides
a lot of out of the box features drag
and drop features which we will talk
about in our subsequent sessions and you
know classes but today's session is
primarily focused on giving you guys an
introduction on what is the purpose of
power bi and what all problems it solve
uh in the in the real world so power bi
allows you to view analyze and visualize
huge quantities of data and the data
could be in any format Excel CSV text or
it could be a direct connection to a
database like SQL MySQL Azure Oracle
anyone IBM db2 so it supports n number
of uh you know data types or data sets
and it's very powerful in terms of data
connectivity
so it uses powerful compression
algorithms to import and Cachet the data
within the dot pbix file so it's as
convenient as a simple software if
suppose you import a data and then you
prepare a report and then you can easily
share the reports with your peers or
someone who's co-developing with you
either through Power bi cloud services
or even you can share the pbix file in
an email
or through any other means and you can
share the data set with the concern and
they can then work on the report
independently so there are different
ways there is no uh kind of a limitation
for you know working on power bi there
are multiple ways and it is very fast it
is the most fast uh tool to work with
Excel because definitely Excel is also a
Microsoft Technology so it works very
fast on Excel based data and gives you
numbers and Reporting at a very high
speed
so now once you have imported the data
power bi allows you to model the data
allows you to work intelligently on the
data it allows you to model data in a
way that if you are importing data from
multiple Excel sheets importing data
from multiple tables you can easily
create a relationship between those
tables or data sets in power bi and then
create visually appealing reports
meaningful reports as I've been
emphasizing and make sense out of that
data no data in silos is of any use data
in Silo means a single worksheet or a
single data set will not churn out any
meaningful information until unless you
basically join it clubbit merge it Union
it append it with some other data sets
because a single data set will never be
able to hold that much amount of
information which is generally required
for a you know important report
so it has easy drag and drop
functionality with features that allow
you to copy all formatting across
similar visualizations so just like in
Microsoft Excel we use format painter to
copy the format of one cell to another
similar features very very similar to
excel products or Microsoft product they
have provided that if you have applied a
a particular thing on a report you can
easily replicate that on an any other
report the font uh the header size the
background color you don't need to do it
again and again so there's a lot of
reusable features which are also
available okay now
as I said Excel is a Microsoft product
power bi is a Microsoft product so they
have intercompatibility you can publish
data from Excel to power bi now with the
latest developments and enhancements
as of today pixel has also plugged in a
new feature called Power pivot which
I'll uh show you later down the line but
that also allows you to do a quick
analysis no you can't create of course
complex reports or uh fancy reports like
power bi but Power pivot allows you to
create you know quick measures quick
functions quick calculations on your
data quickly only in Excel so it's an
Excel plugin but whereas you know you
can power bi is also compatible with
Excel so when you create a report in
power bi it gives you inbuilt feature to
export your power bi report into Excel
format directly you don't need to do any
programming for it also
you can easily publish when you publish
your power bi reports it allows you to
give some inbuilt intelligence of
analyzing your reports in Excel and it
gives you all those of all those
features of exporting your power bi
reports into Excel which is not
available in any other tool or otherwise
those tools have to create plugins
create add-ins and probably they might
charge for it but Power bi comes with
lot of out of the box features which are
very very helpful for analyzing data in
Excel and vice versa
Azure Cloud now Azure itself again is a
Microsoft cloud Tech stack so using
power bi with Azure allows you to
analyze and share large volumes of data
so Azure basically Azure database or
Azure Cloud servers are meant to hold
huge amount of data and power bi allows
you to have seamless connection you can
easily connect to Azure data Lake
you can reduce the time it takes to get
insights and increase collaboration
between business analysts data engineers
and data scientists so azure
data Lake becomes the central focal
point where all your analysts Engineers
can keep working on on the centralized
piece of data and churn out their
reports data scientists primarily job is
to keep the data in a structured way
optimized way optimize the input output
operations disk operations and memory
utilization so that the reports also get
churned out in a faster manner so every
uh you know every person has their own
role in order to give a quick
refreshable report a quick rendered
report any report which is taking huge
amount of time to get rendered will not
eventually be used by the business users
because then it does not solve the
purpose the report should be fast
reports should have uh you know
appropriate filters slices and dices you
should be able to you know create the
reports or dynamically or you should be
able to analyze visualize the data
dynamically so all those visualization
features are available in power bi and
it works seamlessly either it is small
data or huge data it allows that you to
work on those kind of data in a seamless
fashion
right so this is just a very uh quick uh
example of how our typical dashboard
looks like dashboard is nothing but you
know you have clubbed a couple of
multiple reports on a single page and
you know if you change a filter uh a
single filter on the page all the
reports will honor that filter and the
numbers will change accordingly so if
you see the in this example there is a
filter or a drop down or product ID
product name employee name or supervisor
or a date range so whatever date range
or filter you will apply all the reports
on this dashboard will get changed based
on the filter you have selected so power
bi allows you to get insights from data
and turn insights into action to take
data driven business decision and that
is the ultimate goal of any
visualization tool that is the purpose
for which visualization tools are bought
uh and purchased by the organizations
and data is fed into them
Now power bi fetches data from Factory
sensors social media sources to get
access to real-time Analytics so that
you are always ready to make timely
business decisions so so basically there
is a a feature of live connection or cut
off data connection so either you can
work on data which is deciding on a
machine and you can just work on the
cutoff data like for example it's
there's a data which is available for
sales 2017 2018 and you're just working
on a historical data it's a cut off data
or it could be possible that you want to
be connected live uh to a real-time iot
based sensor based data or social media
data like Twitter Facebook feeds or you
know you're connected to live Google
worksheets that is also possible you
just need to publish your Google sheet
for a public domain embed that you are
in into Power bi and then whoever
updates that Google sheet automatically
the power bi report will also start
honoring and consuming the new data
which is added in the Google sheet so
all those kind of real-time streaming
analytics is also possible and that is
one big feature and very important
feature of power bi which is widely used
and has a very huge uh you know Market
acceptance and Market utilization
now what is power bi
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by Microsoft that lets you
visualize your data and share insights
right so earlier
you know uh
Microsoft used to have a technology
called ssas now they have replaced
actually ssas and SSRS with power bi so
basically you can use power bi on the
data which is there in your Excel or any
other data source and the power bi
service or power bi desktop basically
creates a connection to those data sets
and import it cache it and give you a
handle to it in order to work with it so
you can create these fancy meaningful
visualizations like for example there's
a geographical map if you are importing
data for a country or a continent or a
region power bi will automatically
detect that it's a geographical
information and give you a map with
latitude longitude information and you
just need to plot
your uh your numbers on the map either
you can use bubbles or either you can
use triangles or whatever data structure
you want to use but all the mapping will
be available geographically then you can
create pie charts which is shown in this
visualization you can create tree maps
you can create cards where you know you
can highlight the most important numbers
like sales total sales of your company
across all the regions or the growth
chart or the month on month uh you know
sales of your organization or number of
total number of products or units sold
so whatever is important and to be
highlighted for the management to take
any meaningful decision or any insights
you want to share power bi visualization
tool the power bi visualization uh
uh chart allows you to drag and drop and
create wonderful reports okay
so what are the features of power bi so
power bi desktop is something a
standalone tool which you need to
install on your machine it allows you to
build reports by accessing data easily
you do not need Advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report though yes it is beneficial that
if you know uh some SQL programming
analytical programming or you are aware
of advanced features of any analytical
tool that might help you but that's not
a showstopper you can easily build
reports in quick turnaround time without
needing any technical background you
just need to have some analytical uh
mindset and you can create uh Savvy
visualization and you know analytical
reports
stream analytics as I mentioned you can
create a live connection uh with any
kind of data it could be iot it could be
media social media it could be Google
Docs it could be uh you know any other
kind of uh you know live connection it
could be a live database connection
itself so any insertions or updations or
deletions happening will automatically
reflect in your report
yes multiple data sources and that has
to be the primary criteria for any tool
to be popular if any visualization tool
is limited to certain data sets then you
know it will not be highly acceptable in
the market
and custom visualizations right so as I
showed you certain uh examples in the
past in the previous presentation uh
that feature is very important because
someone might want to look the kpis look
at the kpis from a different perspective
some management might want to look at
the kpis from a different perspective so
you need to you need to have that
capability to create different
visualization from the same data set now
let's take a look at how
to install power bi desktop on your
machine
so basically what you need to do is
you need to go to this URL
power bi dot microsoft.com en US desktop
okay
and you need to just
enter this
now you can download it for free so just
click over here
and
it will open Microsoft store so
basically now what Microsoft have done
in the latest operating systems is that
when you are trying to download you can
actually directly go to the Microsoft
store
and search for Power bi
so let's wait for a couple of seconds
right here so power bi desktop in
Microsoft store for me it's already
installed so it's asking me to open it
I'll open it in a while but for you for
anyone who is not installed he will see
the button of install over here and it
will automatically install in your
machine and then you can easily go and
open power bi desktop now if I click
open over here
now this is the
uh UI of the power bi desktop I'm not
going to go right now in creating
reports right away we will talk about
that in a subsequent session with sample
data sets and we will cover the features
of power bi desktop one by one but this
is what it is this is the whole tool of
power bi which is having the
visualization pane all the different
visualizations are you know can be
created from this pane then this is the
pane which allows you to select the data
data fields then there is a report view
data View and relationship view the data
model view where multiple relationships
you can create you can view the data in
the grid
of the tables which you will create and
the reports so you can create multiple
reports on multiple Pages you can keep
adding pages either you can drag create
multiple reports on a single page and it
will become a dashboard or you can
create separate independent reports on
the single page
and these are the menu options which we
will talk about how you can change color
scheming you can do data modeling you
can create new reports and you can also
transform data which is the biggest
feature extract transform and load the
data apply different logic changing data
types massaging the information creating
new joins appending the data you know
adding new columns etc etc uh we that is
what you can do in transform data so
this itself is a whole different world
it's a dedicated topic so we will talk
about that in our subsequent sessions so
what's in it for us today we will be
learning how to connect to data
different data types data files like
Excel PDF then what are the different
data importing modes and then I will
also show you practically different sets
how to import them in power bi and use
it for your visualization purpose now
what are the steps to connect to data so
now we will go directly into Power bi
and try to import one by one few most
commonly and popularly used data sets
which are most commonly used in a
day-to-day activity rest of course there
are power bi supports n number of data
sources but we will do something
practical on the most popular ones so
let's let's open our power bi
now this is my power bi and first I want
to show you that how can I import data
directly from a web page and import the
data now it is asking for a URL in order
to import data so what I have done is I
have created a Google Excel sheet with
simple data with rows and columns and
what I have done is I have shared this
sheet as published to web
okay so you just need to say publish to
the web the link as web page and
say done it's it's automatically
published and say link so copy the link
which you have published on the web copy
this link
and then go back to your tableau
paste that link over here and click ok
Now power bi will try to establish a
connection with this Google doc sheet
because it's published on the web
you need to wait for a while while it is
reading
okay now it has read one of the HTML
tables I'll select this one now you can
see it has it is showing me a preview of
the table which is there on my
Google sheet right it has 11 rows so it
has all showed all the 11 rows so now I
can go and transform this data because I
can see my headers are there starting
from the second row so there is an
opportunity for me to transform the data
so I'll go and transform it so that it
looks clean
okay so first is I need to remove the
first row which is the
null row remove the top rows
okay and then I need to use the first
row now as a header so you just click
this option use first row as headers
set so now if you see my row ID order ID
order date ship date all my data is now
ready so I can say close and apply
click apply changes
now this is an example of web data
import you can go and preview your data
right now the biggest advantage of this
data connection is that it's a live data
so for example I insert another row
let me change the order ID
some some I've sub change some basic
stuff and I
it's Auto saved
Ctrl s now I'll go to my tableau and
I'll refresh
now you can see as I refreshed my
power query editor I click refresh all
and I got my new row which is there in
the live data I got that fetched from my
okay I got that row the row number ID
number 12 so I have to sit close and
apply
now you can see the new row the row
number 12 is now available in my new
data set in the data set because it's a
live connection it's a live connection
with the web based Google sheet okay so
this is one important way in which you
can import data
now let's try to import data from a text
file
now I have already prepared our text
file called
sub categories Dot txt
now let me just open it in a notepad now
it's a very plain simple file tab
separated file in which you have product
subcategory ID subcategory name and
product category key so basically to
which product category this particular
sub product belongs to right so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna go back to my
get data option
and I'm gonna select text slash CSV
option
and I'm gonna select option mod product
subcategories Dot txt
okay so now power bi has identified that
it's a tab delimited file it has
recognized the headers
Etc right and I can now directly load
this file
okay
so now once the data is imported in
power bi it is like
irrelevant to me it's a composite data
in input I'm doing right so in my
presentation when I'm talking about
importing data there are different
importing modes right import our data
import can happen through different ways
okay
one is direct query mode in which I
create a live connection to the database
which I'll also show you uh using MySQL
and Ms SQL server and also you can do a
composite mode in which you can have
data imported from Excel plus you can
have direct query modes so you can have
multiple uh modes to connect and create
a composite data model and that's what
we are doing right now in our practical
so what we are doing over here is one we
have imported data from the web second
we have imported data from a text table
now after doing text now our next task
is to import from CSV let's try another
one so now I have imported product
subcategory
now I'll import
a CSV file so again I'll choose the
option Text slash CSV and now in this
CSV file let me open this CSV file and
show you what it is it
so this is a list of all my products
product key products of category Key
Products stock keeping unit Etc a simple
CSV file and I'm gonna import that
okay so now it is identified the
delimiter is comma rather than a tab and
it has already recognized the headers
correctly so I load it
okay so now my products are there
product subcategories are there for
product categories now what I have done
is I have created a Excel mode now so
now Excel I am using to import my
product category
so now I have to click on the option of
import data from Excel and I'll say
product categories
select the sheet load
and now so my products product
categories product sub categories do
with different uh data storage types but
still now the data is imported into
Power bi is a composite data model now
another very important data type which
you can import is the PDF also right so
what I have done is I have created a PDF
called customers my customers data is
lying in a PDF so what I've done is I've
created a PDF
which has data for some columns are
there like you know customer key prefix
first name last name birth date marital
status gender email address annual
income total children etc etc so this is
the data set
which I have created in PDF so what I'm
going to do is
I'm going to select PDF now
and import customers.pdf
and see it has recognized my table on
page one which I am going to load
okay
you can rename this as PDF
table
okay so this basically these are the
different type of
data
types we have imported PDF Excel text
CSV and web page
now let's take a look at another
interesting data set which you want to
import is the my SQL Server data set
so what I have done is I've already
installed MySQL server on my local
instance and there's already a schema of
SQL live tutorial over there and I have
certain tables already
prepared over there like Department
employee Etc so my goal is now to import
this data or create a live connection
with this data set
now in order to import
my SQL database Connection in power bi
you need to First
download a
connector MySQL power bi connector so
you need to go to this link
and then click on download and install
the MySQL connector based on the
operating system you have you click on
download and install it
after you have done this go back to
Power bi
and then give
the IP address of the database in my
case it's there in this local machine
and the schema which I want to import is
SQL live tutorial so I'll give the name
click connect
okay now it's connected so now it is
asking me which particular tables you
want to create a connection with I am
choosing department and employee
and I'm just loading them
okay so now this is the exact data which
is there in the employee and Department
in MySQL okay so this is one example of
how to create connectivity between power
bi and MySQL now I want to do the same
thing using
SQL Server Microsoft SQL Server so I
have also installed Microsoft SQL server
on my machine
and I have used the SQL Express so this
is the name of my server so which I'll
copy the server name and
go to get data
select SQL Server
and for now database is optional I can
say direct query click ok
now it is showing me what all tables I
can import so in my SQL Server tutorial
in my SQL Server I have
I have these three tables customers
employee attrition Olympic events so I
can use probably the customers one which
is
now you can see this is the data the
customer's data which is lying in my SQL
Server okay so I can preview it and load
it
so now you can you can preview the data
in uh Power bi that is this is the data
so I can rename his customers from
Ms SQL
and this is from
MySQL
and
okay so now
this is not the only data
sets you can import now if you take a
look at the options which power bi gave
what different type and variations of
data it can it has compatibility to
import from
okay so we can just take a look at the
categorization on the left hand side
first there are file based like Excel
text XML Json is also possible you can
evenly directly import entire folder and
within the folder whatever uh data types
of files are there it will detect it PDF
power key or even SharePoint folder
which is itself from Microsoft uh
technology then different kind of
databases SQL server and MySQL we just
saw but it's not only limited to this
you can connect to Microsoft Access
ssas Oracle database IBM db2 postgres
SCI base teradata and then sap
databases Amazon redshift Impala vertica
Snowflake and N number of databases
which are there in the market today
Amazon
Etc
then it also allows you to connect with
its own power platforms power bi
platforms data mods power bi data flows
dataverse Etc
Azure there are different kind of
storage
mechanisms in Azure and Azure itself is
a Microsoft Technology so it has a
compatibility of a lot of azure uh based
data storages like Azure SQL database
blob storage uh Azure data breaks right
Azure HD insights path so if you have
those kind of services running on your
observed cloud services you can even
import them over here
now online services
like you know you have erps running uh
or some data which is shared on the
internet if you want to import it uh
that is also possible through certain
products uh Dynamics 365 Microsoft
Exchange online Salesforce Google
analytics Adobe analytics GitHub
LinkedIn sales if you want to do some
analysis of some social networking uh
you know feeds that also you can import
then other miscellaneous are also their
web-based hive R script python script if
there's something to import get data
from uh Google Sheets like we store one
example in our video right now so there
are multiple options available
now once you have imported the data
which is relevant to you
um in our subsequent sessions we will
see how to create relationships but just
giving you a glimpse that whatever data
you are importing power bi Auto detects
certain relationships and it will create
for you but then you can go and manually
also change so this is the composite
data model which is getting created in
the back end while you are importing the
data you can easily go and manage these
relationships either keep them as is you
can delete and create new ones manually
so there is no limitation in that
so this is what we have witnessed we
have imported data from different files
types data types and then you know we
have tried once it is imported into uh
Power bi then there is no limitation of
how you use it you can create
visualization across different data sets
and then create your
standard reports
so this is the example of importing data
from web importing data from a database
from a PDF
and then once you have data you can
shape and combine data you can basically
do what whatever transformation you want
to do you want to make joins merge the
data so for example if we go back to our
power bi and if I go back to my
transform data section
now as I have now different data sets
available with me I have I can do any
kind of you know operation
transformation on the data right uh
so like I showed you I uh upgraded the
header row because one of the imported
data was not showing the header
correctly uh or this columns like this
exact one column is extra I can remove
the column
right all those Transformations whatever
I do in the back end gets captured in
the applied steps section right
this is the customer data you can create
uh you can merge it you can append it uh
you know with other data sets right
let's for example I want to create a
merge data set of my categories and sub
categories so I can say more selectors
two data sets and say merge queries as
new
and
and I can select product categories and
products are categories select
product category key on both the sides
and then they do a left Auto Zone so
whatever product categories are there
I'll get the subcategories associated
with it and I'll create a new table
which will have
now I have the table which has the
category and the subcategory and
subcategory in one table itself so I can
rename it now to as
category
sub category
table it's a it's a merge basically it's
a join between category and subcategory
and now I have a common table right and
I can close and apply
so imagine I have created a
new table which is imported created from
one data set is which is Excel page
another data set which is text based
see this category subcategory table so
now I can use it
the way I want
in my visualization reports so that's
what the presentation says right that
once you have uh the imported data you
can shape you can combine you can adjust
you can do whatever transformation you
want to do and create your visualization
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we are going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after you've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data uh is also called as a fat and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
ancient so this is a typical dimensional
data model which is typically used uh
sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which is processed and you will make a
join between customer and product table
and even you can make a join between
product or product type or customer or
product types customer table will also
have a key to the product type so this
is less conducive for reporting but it
is more of a transactional relational
model but of course this is also
feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and this is what we are going to see in
our example now so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna show you certain data sets
first we will prepare and create certain
offer data sets and then we will Import
in our sample power bi file and then
slowly slowly we will create the
relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm gonna show you okay so if I
open a power bi and this is where the
option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality
now before I start playing around with
my data and start showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
one is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order ID might have a multiple
fulfillments for the same order ID so
there will be a multi many to many
relationship which I'll show you
practically so now with this background
let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the Master data so first I'll import
all my master Dimensions which are uh
which I'm going to you know use in my
example so first is the customers table
customers data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I reported
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
uh join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is detected by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product site
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for simplicity's
sake you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here product key is also there and
it is what we wanted so one is too many
relationship from product to sales table
and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
and for each customer in front of each
customer name the count is coming as 293
293 it is getting repetitive because
because there is a one-way filter
Direction filter between customers and
sales and sales and products right so
this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
site filter
So when you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now for T20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293 now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and products
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct
okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example they where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to give show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
but what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of 1 is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my
fulfillment data set
foreign
data set there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has
um
uh Power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many-to-many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter detection uh a Direction
but you can you can check that but
definitely uh Power bi shows a warning
that this relationship has cardinality
to many to many and this should only be
used if it is expected that neither
column contains unique values okay so we
know that fact that's why we are
accepting this relationship as many to
many because we know there are multiple
order numbers over here in the sales
table which are mapped to the multiple
order numbers in the Fulfillment table
we'll click ok
now you want to keep uh the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to
map the report so I can double click
over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
I put over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
and so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model now so far what we have done
as per our last session is that we did
data modeling on the different data sets
which we had imported in power bi like
products sales data returns fulfillment
customer details and customer Master
data calendar details Etc so in the last
session we prepared a data model and
established the relationships between
these different data sets like one is to
one one is too many many to one one is
to one Etc and we saw the examples now
once our relational model is prepared
our data model is prepared now our next
activity is to create certain additional
columns which we want to derive basis
the data which we have imported
so for example I'll start with my
product data set now in my product data
set I want to introduce a column which
basically
categorizes that if any product which
has a color uh you know red black or
gray I am going to tag it as a colored
product rest I'm gonna say not a colored
product right so all these are like
example of byte type product skus so for
that now in order to introduce a new
column you just need to do what you need
to select the table in the data grid go
to the table tools and say new column
okay so column will get appended to the
rightmost part and you will start seeing
a uh formula section typical to like you
get in your Excel now I'm gonna say that
the name of my column is going to be
byte type color okay and I'm just
creating a if condition if
product
color
is equal to
black
okay
or
or if it is equal to red
or if it is equal to
Gray
then
say yes it's a colored product I'll say
no
okay so now you can see this is the
product color red and black they are
saying byte type color Yes blue is no
multi is no etc etc so this is a classic
example of an if and else condition
based conditional column
okay so you can create such columns now
second column custom column which I want
to create is I'm going to call as
discount
now this is the pricing of my products I
want to associate certain discounts
which I am ready to give to my customers
this is the product category like what
is the pricing of the category again I'm
going to use make use of if else but in
a nested way so if I am saying if my
product
price is less than 100
then I will give
zero percent off
uh zero percentage of discount so 0 into
product price just to keep it consistent
now I'm saying
else
if less than 100 and 0 else I'll check
again that
if
the price is
less than
500 then I'm ready ready to give one
percent discount
on the product price
else
I'll move further so like this
I have created a formula
so what I'm saying is if product price
is less than 100 give zero percent if it
is less than 500 then give one percent
less than 2 000 then 1.5 percent less
than three thousand then two percent and
otherwise else less than three thousand
if a two percent else three percent
right now after this column is created
now you can check right so this C the
product price for this particular
product it is less than 100 so that's
why there is no discount it is uh
between 100 to 200 then this has been
given a one percent discount so like
this all the discount column is now
calculated now this column is available
just like a regular column in my product
table
now after this I'll go to my sales table
now in sales table I want to identify
and uh
create a column called as cost
there is no product cost column over
here so that will be derived
so let's create a column
called as cost
and it is derived by order quantity
into now the cost of the product
is in the product table and I know I
have already created a relationship
between product and sales table
so I just need to select the product
cost column now only keyword which I
have to use in power bi is the related
keyword so this will pick up the
relation
and now for this particular sale order
the cost has already been derived so
this order number this is the cost for
which uh the product has is the costing
of the product for this particular order
you do
okay
now I'm gonna create another conditional
column over here called as
order status
I'm saying if
any order whose order quantity is
greater than 2
then for my organization it's an urgent
order
else it is a
normal order
oh sorry
lost it
so this is my
order status column and I have my order
quantity
urgent or normal
so any order which has order quantity 1
is normal any order which is having
order quantity as greater than
2 is
urgent you can see this
so there's a this whole power bi
uh tabs and sheets allow you to also
review the data what you're doing so
it's very convenient
now
I have my sales data now what I want to
bring within the sales is my discount
column so here also I want to bring the
discount which I have created
so I'll say discount
[Music]
will be order quantity
into
related
product discount right so the discount
calculated column which I had created
under products I'll bring over here
now I am creating the order level
discount so if you see for this
particular order there's a 25 uh
uh you know for 25 rupee discount at the
cost is 100 000 rupees okay
and what is the order price now so I
have taken the order cost the discount
now I have to create a column call as
price order price so that will be
again order quantity
into related
price which is per product
price and
okay so now I have the cost the discount
and the price right available with me
now I want to
calculate the total
uh
total revenue total profit and loss
right
per order how much
so first I'll calculate per order how
much revenue I am generating so now I
have to generate a column called as
Revenue
revenue is price
minus discount
so 1700 minus 25
1700 minus 25 2071 minus 42 and if I
want to calculate the profit per order
then it is
Revenue
Minus cost
okay so now you can see you know typical
custom columns calculated columns which
you have created are all playing around
with the number numeric values numeric
data primarily and trying to give
inferences into per order cost discount
per order price revenue and profit so
typical calculation columns which I have
prepared in front of you
now let's take a look at other different
variations of custom columns
I'll create certain columns for text
based custom columns calculated columns
using Text data
so I'm now moving towards my customer
table in which I have customer key
prefix first name last name birth date
marital status and gender
now I want to create a new column in
which I want to derive the age of each
customer as of today right so I'll use
another function a date function called
as
date div
now date div so I want the difference
between the birth date of the customer
and as of today
in years
okay so this customer as of today 68
year old one is 74 68 57 Etc so this is
one derivation of a calculated column of
age
let's take another example now this is a
text based column where I want to
derive the full name of the customer
now here I'll say first
lowercase in lower case I'll concatenate
the prefix
then ampersand
space
ampersand
first name
Ampersand space
ampersand
last name
and closing brackets
Etc
full name
okay so this is an example of full name
in low cases
now another
calculated column conditional column at
the customer level
I want to identify a flag which says who
is my Target customer base is the
demographics shared over here Target
customer
so I'll say
if
the marital status is equal to
m
and
total children
hurry
and total children annual income
so okay so let me change the logic a bit
so marital status is M and
age
is
less than
these customers are my Target customers
okay so I would say
yes
else no
see this
he is a marital status is married Logan
Diaz and age is less than 50 else
everyone so if I try to filter
so these are the my Target customers
69 out of 1178 so this is just a
conditional column but a logical
condition an example which I am trying
to highlight over here
okay now
let's look at certain calendar
date oriented columns calculated columns
very typical like now I have a simple
date column now I'll keep adding certain
columns which are you know which help
you which will help you understand how
we can uh
you know do some calculations on the
dates so like for example I want a date
which is 12 days after the current date
the date in the column so just simple 12
Days After
select the date and add 12.
now if you see the date format you can
go and change the format at the top
and if whatever you feel like like this
now see 12 days after first Jan 2015 is
13 Jan 2005. you can go and change the
format and other details
let me also show you if I go to my cost
and other columns I can go and change
the format this is like a currency cost
is currency so I can go and
select the
change the currency type and you can
even show the dollar value or whatever
currency type it is
so for numbers you can do currency or
text or dates you can select the format
so this is available at the column tools
level
now in customers
like we had our
column of full name so now what all
things are available format as text okay
data type text so very minimal options
are there with date you have options of
the date format
now next
I want a column which defines the expiry
date okay so eight months prior
to the
expiry date within which is coming up in
eight months so I'll create a column
called as eight months expiry
and then there is a e date function I'll
use that I'll use my
date in the data set
comma I'll say eight so now this date
column will append eight months to my
actual date and again I can go and
change the format
correct
now another important column like I want
to know the date name
so I'll use a function called as
format
and I'll select my calendar date column
and I'll say give me the DDD
format of it so it will give me the day
name the day the day name of on that
particular date
next
years in between
so I want the years in between the
today's date and the date of my calendar
so equal to
D diff
the calendar date
comma today
comma year
end
seven years 2015 to 2022
then last date of the month
so if I want the what is the last date
of this particular calendar month
I will use a function EO month which is
there available in the
power bi so I'll say
last date of the month
equal to
e o month
then
just select the calendar CSV date
comma
0 in months and enter
change the format
then similarly start of the month
so I'll use a function called start of
month
so for for all January dates end of the
month is 31st Jan and start of the month
will remain 1st of January
change the format
foreign
next I want to know what is the weak
number of that particular date so now
there is an inbuilt function called
week number week num and just pass the
date and you will get
the weak number first week of the year
second week of the year Etc
now another very
good example is whether the weak
day is a weekday or a weekend right so
what is it's a weak type okay
so I'll check I'll put a if condition
and there is a function called weekday
and I'll pass the calendar
if it is less than 6
it means it's a weekday as it's a
weekend
so all Saturday
and Sunday D names will come as weekends
or else everything else will come as
weekly let's embark on this
transformative adventure together I hope
I made myself clear with the agenda that
said if you are an aspiring business
analyst looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns post-graduate program and
business analytics from third University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below also if you are
already a business analyst and want to
upgrade your skills to become a
successful data scientist with proper
training and certification from the
experts and reputed universities then
Caltech data science boot camp should be
the right choice for more details use
the link in the description box below
now today we will discuss how to create
relationships and different kind of data
models within power bi based on the
structure of data you're importing
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we are going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after we've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know less frequently
changing data sets so there is an
organization right and you have set of
customers their email ID phone numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data is also called as a fat and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
patient so this is a typical dimensional
data model which is typically used uh
sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which is processed and you will make a
join between customer and product table
and even you can make a join between
product or product type or customer or
product type customer table will also
have a key to the product type so this
is less conducive for reporting but it
is more of a transactional relational
model but of course this is also
feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and they this is what we are going to
see in our example now so what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna show you certain data
sets first we will prepare and create
certain offer data sets and then we will
Import in our sample power bi file and
then slowly slowly we will create the
relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm going to show you okay so
if I open a power bi and this is where
the option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
uh keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality
now before I start playing around with
my data and start showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
one is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order
ID might have a multiple fulfillments
for the same order ID so there will be a
multi many to many relationship which
I'll show you practically so now with
this background let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the Master data so first I'll import
all my master Dimensions which are which
I'm gonna you know use in my example so
first is the customers table customers
data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I'll import it
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is directed by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product side
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for Simplicity sake
you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here and product key is also there
and it is what we wanted so one is too
many relationship from product to sales
table and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
and for each customer in front of each
customer name the count is coming as 293
293 it is getting repetitive because
because there is a one-way filter
Direction filter between customers and
sales and sales and products right so
this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
site filter
so when do you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now for T20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293 now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and product
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct
okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example they where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to give show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of one is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my
fulfillment data set
foreign
data set there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has
um
uh Power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many-to-many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter detection uh a Direction
but you can you can check that but
definitely uh Power bi shows a warning
that this relationship has cardinality
to many to many and this should only be
used if it is expected that neither
column contains unique values okay so we
know that fact that's why we are
accepting this relationship as many to
many because we know there are multiple
order numbers over here in the sales
table which are mapped to the multiple
order numbers in the Fulfillment table
we'll click ok
now you want to keep uh the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to
map the report so I can double click
over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have uh uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
map it over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
and so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry uh the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model
hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and Implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met Target
as a data set can be huge and complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently conditional
formatting a type of formatting helps us
visually explore and analyze data detect
critical issues and identify patterns
and trends conditional formatting helps
to add patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula Etc
at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set
Excel provides a large number of logical
statistical and mathematical functions
such as vlookup hlookup and if not rank
quartile and many more that can help the
users to perform calculations ranging
from basic to complex operations
these inbuilt functions help us to
manage data and perform descriptive
statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of inbuil excel
functions before going into details let
us start this lesson by defining the
objectives of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it
we can format the cells in Microsoft
Excel manually by selecting fonts font
color font size background colors and
borders we can also use numerous
predefined table Styles or quick styles
to quickly format a table automatically
this is the basic formatting in Excel
if these built-in functions do not meet
our needs or do not display the data in
the format that we require we can create
our own custom format in this topic we
will focus on custom formatting in Excel
let's say we want to display one million
five hundred and thirty two thousand as
1.53 M or the 1st of January 2016 date
with a weekday as the first Friday
January 2016. here we can use custom
formatting feature of excel let's see
how we can accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales
suppose we want to display the values of
net sales in terms of thousands for
example
7164 should be displayed at 7.16 k
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format sales dialog box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number 0 decimal zero zero comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation
each comma after decimal 0 0
indicate divide value by one thousand
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places
the K component displays a literal K
character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is 7.16 K
finally click OK button
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as 1st Jan 2012. we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012.
first select the column containing dates
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cell dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter DD Dash DDD
Dash mmm YY
here d stands for date m stands for
month and y stands for year
the first 2dd is the date
the next four DDD is for weekday say
Thursday
then mmm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year
here we can see in the preview in the
sample box the value shown is one Sunday
Jan 12.
finally click on OK button
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs
a worksheet may contain thousands of
rows of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and Trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and data bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than five thousand color the
cell yellow
by applying this rule we will be able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5000 let us
understand this with the help of
examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values
first select the order ID column
clip Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values
a duplicate values dialog box appears
select a formatting style from the drop
down menu in our example we will choose
green fill with dark green text click ok
here we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID
Excel highlights all the duplicate cells
with green fill with dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains
a date occurring and top slash bottom
rules
all these rules work in the similar
format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to apply the icon set rule
if sales amount is greater than 8 000
then a green arrow should appear in the
upward Direction
if sales amount is between five thousand
and eight thousand then show a yellow
arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than five
thousand then show a red arrow in the
downward Direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
go to Icon set Rule and select three
icon set rule
click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33
percentile rule this means that it shows
a green arrow for values greater than 67
percent
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33 percent and red arrow for values less
than 33 percent
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria
in the type drop down select the option
as number
in the value reference box enter value
is 8 000 for green color arrow and 5000
for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color Arrow click ok
in the conditional formatting rules
manager window click ok
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8 000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction
values between 5K and 8K are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5K are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table wherever
profit is greater than four thousand
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting
select the option new rule from the drop
down a new formatting rule dialog box
appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format
under format values reference box enter
the formula as equals if Open Bracket
dollar sign H2 greater than four
thousand comma true comma false close
bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than four thousand
click on format button
from the format cells dialog box select
the fill tab from the color dialog box
select the color as green
finally click ok
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than four thousand are
highlighted with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false
in this topic we will cover various
logical functions like if and or not
true false
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesman
following is the criteria if net sales
greater than or equal to ten thousand
set commission as five percent
if net sales greater than or equal to
5000 and less than or equal to ten
thousand set commission as 2.5 percent
if net sales less than five thousand set
commission as one point five percent
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function
let's write the formula in cell I5
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function e if and then type an open
parenthesis the first parameter we need
to pass is a logical test here The
Logical test is if sales cell G5 greater
than or equal to ten thousand assign
value as five percent
then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket sale at
cell G5 greater than or equal to five
thousand comma cell G5 less than or
equal to ten thousand comma assign value
as 2.5 percent
in the else parameter we will type 1.5
percent this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
IFS thus Excel Returns the result as 2.5
percent for cell G5
now drag the formula with the help of
the fill handle we can see the results
for the other cells as well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10 000 or
profit greater than 5000 set remark as
good
else set remark as needs Improvement
let's write the formula using IF and or
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
ten thousand comma H5 greater than or
equal to five thousand comma double
quote good double quote comma double
quote need Improvement double quote
close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true false true
slash false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function
if result is true it returns false else
true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell L5
this Returns the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup match index and
offset function
the vlookup function lets us search for
specific information in the current
worksheet
say we have a list of students with
marks
we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the hlookup function
consider the extract from our Master
sales table
the table depicts sales information
based on order ID Products sold salesman
and net sales now we want to determine
the net sales corresponding to order ID
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I2 to
add the formula
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function name
vlookup and then type and open
parentheses
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for
so in our example it will be order
id1121 cell H2
the second argument is table array table
array is the cell range that contains
the data in this example our data is in
cell B2 to e40.
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal
vlookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma four comma false close bracket
we can see that the function Returns the
value as 2 2 7 7.
note that the vlookup function works
from left to right that means the lookup
value should always be present in the
leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the hlookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I4 we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name
hlookup and then type open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be order ID
equals one one two one
cell eight four
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as11
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses
so our function has the form equals
hlookup Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fault close bracket
the function Returns the value 2277 note
that each lookup function works from
left to right that means lookup value
should always be in the topmost row of
your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array
let us understand its functioning with
the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell E5
type equal sign
then type the function name
match and then type an open parenthesis
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell B5
the second argument is lookup array
the lookup array is a range of cells
that contains the value we are searching
for in this example we will select the
cells B17 to b1342
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1. the value
should be 1. if we want to find the
largest value less than or equal to the
lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be -1 if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value
here we will pass the match type as 0 as
we require an exact match
finally close the parentheses
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
B dollar sign one three four two comma
zero close bracket
this Returns the value as three now we
can drag the formula across cells with
the help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell E3 to determine the position of
the shown field name Excel C3 in range
B17 to I17 for example net sales is at
seventh position in the range B17 to I17
let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3
for second argument select cells B17 to
I17
past third argument is zero finally
close the parentheses
so our function looks like equal match
Open Bracket C3 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
I dollar sign Seventeen comma zero close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8.
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function Returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list
suppose we want to determine the value
of a field mentioned in cell C3 from the
sales table on a specified date
the table should dynamically fetch the
value if the value of the cell C3 is
changed
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
if we write net sales in cell C3 then
formula should fetch net sales value for
specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cell C5 write formula as equal
sign index and open parentheses
the first argument is the array for our
example enter B17 colon i1342
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is column
this corresponds to the column number
that has the value we want to return
here we will enter E3 which denotes the
position of the field name in cell C3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula Returns the value as
6528 based on the position at cells E5
this is the net sales value on the date
the 2nd of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell
now let's understand how to use it
select cell D5
right formula is equal sign offset and
open parentheses the first argument is
the reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as B17
the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number
so for our example we will enter E5
minus 1. here we are subtracting 1 to
match number of row which have the value
and the offset from the reference cell
the third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by 1 to
match with the offset referencing
finally close the parentheses
the function Returns the value based on
the position of date from cell B5 and
field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or
chi-square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sumif
countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
sumifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sumifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sumifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell N4 type equal sign then
type the function name sumifs and then
type an open parentheses the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells H4 to H 1328
the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here we
will pass the range that holds
salesman's name cells E4 to E 1328.
the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell M4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function Returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function Works in a similar
manner like sumifs it counts the number
of cells in a given range when certain
criteria is met
say in the given sales table we want to
determine the total number of sales for
net sales greater than 8 000. to
determine the count we will use the
countifs function so let's write the
formula in cell N5 type the equal sign
then type the function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to h1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than 8 000. finally close
the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria
cell N5 reflects the total number of
sales as 445 for net sales greater than
eight thousand
in this topic we will learn how to use
the function's percentile quartile
standard deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell n6 write the formula as
equal sign percentile Open Bracket
select the column net sales H4 to
h1328 as our first argument
pass the second argument as 0.4 in order
to find the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5220 this means that 40 percent of the
net sales is less than or equal to 5220.
the next function is quartile quartile
function depicts the results for the
first second third and fourth quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to 25
percent let's use the quartile function
to calculate this
select cell N7 to write the formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces
select net sales column H4 to
h1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 and 4. the function returns a
value as
3822 which means that 25 percent of the
sale is less than or equal to 3822.
note that here we can use the percentile
function to perform the same task the
function percentile H4 to
h1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same
result it's up to us which function we
would like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations stdev
[Music]
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean
say we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of customers
so write the formula in cell N8 as
equals
the function name stdev
open braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function Returns the result 1.4
the median function Returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces
select net sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as 6192
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales select cell j4
and write the formula as equal sign then
type the function name rank and then
type in open parenthesis the first
argument is the number
this is the value whose rank we are
required to calculate here we will pass
the argument cell H4
second argument is ref
this corresponds to the array or
reference list here we will select the
column net sales IE cells H4 to H 1328.
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and 1 denotes ascending
order
this argument is optional if we don't
pass any argument Excel automatically
takes the argument zero here we will
pass zero finally close the parentheses
here we can see that Excel has
determined the rank for net sales
7164 as 553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together I hope I made myself
clear with the agenda that said if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
post-graduate program and business
analytics from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below also if you are
already a business analyst and want to
upgrade your skills to become a
successful data scientist with proper
training and certification from the
experts and reputed universities then
Caltech data science boot camp should be
the right choice for more details use
the link in the description box below so
what is Excel macro you do certain daily
tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your Excel and use scrub data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the Excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your Excel you remove certain
columns you add certain things and you
change certain values and these are the
things that you do and N number of times
on an Excel and this can all be done by
simple automated wave which is macros so
what it does is it is a set of tasks
that you can execute as many number of
times as you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes basically if for
example you have your monthly accounts
report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it in extract certain data and
remove certain columns that you do every
time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the absolute values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
in a simple running script called macros
so what you do is you record those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of code or tasks that you can
execute and automate and we can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize the
ribbon click customize ribbon and then
there is a developer tab which you see
here it should be activated so you just
need to select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macros now you you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it all on your
Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts uh recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work
order
accounts and I'll add a little
description like
work order
count scheme
costs
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the laborers the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these of Select data
so I just delete this
okay and then I just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
prefer
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro Save which we ran the
just now and I simply with a single
click I will be able to do these daily
tasks and execute in a Flash so I just
click run and it does the rest for me I
have my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running a simple
macro continuing our uh to work on macro
we can simply do this by a single click
of a button by adding a button so what
you have to do is go to the developer
tab and in the control section you will
see the insert option when you click on
the insert drop down you will see uh
form controls and you can say select a
button and here I select a button and
the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making your answer
work order accounts just to make it
simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
VBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here
so as we see if you go back to the Excel
we see that I received we have been
working on this heat and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure the node I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and I just delete that and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA
so here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use VBA
so
why VBA there are many advantages of
using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel so basically it is a
very simple language it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous section how we
we can simplify your daily task by just
running a simple macro and this VBA
helps us in performing those tasks in a
very simple manner another thing is it
supports english-like statements there
are multiple statements that you can use
and which are very basic English
language statements and this can help us
or it is very easy to program our code
or edit these commands you can select a
range you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we'll
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the VBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your codes for your Excel now how
this is achieved we will see it here now
these are the this is basically the VBA
editor interface where you can see the
uh this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options where in undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window VBA code
window as it says is the code window
where your actual code resides wherein
you can go into it and edit the code or
write the codes and select the different
range of functions that you can perform
and this is basically the bdb VBA code
window where you editor or write your
codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties Windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet2 and it shows the
properties what are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window where then you can run and
execute simple lines of course
individual Excel code that you can run
it will allow you to test individual
lines
which is very useful and handy when
you're writing and debugging course uh
the output if the lines that you execute
can be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the U the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
um Visual Basic for application window
or alternatively you can just go and
click on the Visual Basic and it will
open the sheet video I mean the code
window for you and as we have discussed
before these are the windows that we see
this is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
we can run some testing codes
immediately it will show you the code so
here we see the project Explorer window
where we see the modules and all for our
Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and
columns
[Music]
desperate but can I just save it click
okay
and it has started recording so now what
I'll do is as make it simple and I just
delete some columns here
okay I do not need this I delete this is
there a wait I want this I want the mode
of payment parts cost labor hours I do
not want this some Reflections forget it
okay
and I go for the left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
uh in detail what it looks like so we
see the code what it's doing and what
the macro run has generated the codebook
so we see we have basically the name of
the macro is format columns and what it
is doing we're just selecting The
Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank spreadsheet and I'll try to
explain some basic
functions and the commands and the
quotes that we use to accomplish the
task that we with VBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as it says
it starts with sub and I am specifying
the
module name as number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the code of the macro now uh
I'll explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what is it
used for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword so where exactly I
want to put this you will see it when
you execute the code okay range I am
selecting it should be under course
where I'm going to put the value of x as
and I close the bracket and what should
be the value
we will value should be X so now as I
click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt or F5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain or example some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and I just don't specify it and
we can use date it's basically stores
the date values okay and then again
string so what string does if you use
string it stores the text it can contain
numbers it will have some text as
calculations or anything can be
performed so these are the basic thing
that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to or
use a string value for it and
I put it as string
value
[Music]
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I think I get my code so I put it as
name book it has
Supreme
okay now
I'm trying to use uh
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select Mac
[Music]
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
it goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and four
so I close it
and I put a value rate what value I am
going to assign it is a country
I try to run this code I
hope and see G4 the name populates as
a country here so this is a dim keyword
is being used as a string in our VBA
code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message on an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be executed
using a
code here which I am going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
okay
I'm going to name it as double value and
again the main keyword I'm going to use
the
keyword as double
y double is used is basically it gives a
longer it can be used for a longer form
of single variable ticks it usually
takes more space and larger numbers and
we'll try to assign it okay now I'm
going to pop up a message in this which
says value of a is so and so so I'm
going to give value of a as
250 okay and how I it pops up a message
okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you you can enter
the text and you can edit Library so
here I'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is so and so
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it and let's try to run this
and you will see a message popping
message box popping up
okay so the value of e is the message
box
pops up saying the value of a is 250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
one with some procedures
name
again name
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give anywhere I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
because
this is the
report
let's make it simple
okay
and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I am going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays here name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops a message saying that my name
is it fun so this is a message box that
you can display and I can do anything
with this
[Music]
oh
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define uh
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now I have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
number
and it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
value
is
and it should tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I give a range
[Music]
I have to give it in codes
I'm going to
go to complete
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
A1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so so let's uh
name it as Auto
open
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and what does it say
God's welcome
it's very simple you just run it and
see
crops up a message saying it welcome to
a workshop so these are the one more
this is one more way where you can you
know run a code or to simple welcome
message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
[Music]
so
rename it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I
am going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
cell
now I'm going to
give it as V5
okay to put it as close the parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to E10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean
let me make it very
very cool I give it as B1
through
B
5. as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give a another set of
range here
like let me specify it
[Music]
c one
I have to give it a close
give me another
single
[Music]
call 4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis order the value that I give
is
say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example
wherein you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
comma seven
okay
and I close the parenthesis I assign a
value to it value equals
10. let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
rule six
and column seven
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using VBA so I will show you
how
this is our
let's say selector
range
and I am going to set a dim variable as
a example okay let's say it has example
and what I'm doing is I'm specifying the
range because I'm going to select a
range of cells okay now I'm going to set
the variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a 1 t
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button with a VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value I'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or sales with these
groups
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set up another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay
worksheets I want it in sheet 2 okay so
I just put it a sheet and I activated
basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
two
and what is the range that I'm going to
select the same thing okay
A1
to D5
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet
tool as I'm activating it and I'm going
to assign range and I'm going to select
it so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate
[Music]
okay so what I'm going to do is I am
going to select this range and I'm going
to copy it and paste it somewhere here
okay so let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes
[Music]
of course
okay I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet
and paste it so we are selecting a range
of cells selection and that selection
what we are doing is we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then paste it quite simple
let's
okay see
and
just change it to so it is visible on
this
G5
okay
so this makes quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to get the count or the
number of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the SRB account
it says
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as array and then
what we are going to do is
specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you will count the where
you need the count of the number of
cells so E1 is equal to 85 oops
this is n now how you want the output
you want it you want a message box to
pop up
so you will set up
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay
let's see it says
okay here typing and listed so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
count in this or 20 okay
now let's see I'm going to six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and wherein you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the county number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to should give me
four four
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change it to close
see it says six rows are there
okay
should give me another
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
whoever is in programming are very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the outshoot
output should be such and such we can
specify the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
if it is achieved then you will have to
specify the output as well so this can
be achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result port
so this is one thing and then you can
specify the s or else condition where
you know you specify the condition 2
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Max
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
and
I specify as
okay
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two variables I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass or fail so I specify this
okay dim
score
as specified as integer okay
okay and then there's another variable
that I have to set result
as
the string
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
core I am giving it as a range admin
it's in my
cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
so
it should be a lot
okay
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should give a range for that as
well so I give it in the next column or
any one
this is the basic
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
says press
change to 40
.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
and 75 let's see how it turns
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifying the
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
what should be okay
okay
and now I have to put it user and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay please pass let's see
40 and
again
it's okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving at a range
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use or we're
going to discuss is the
Loop statement that is the for Loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and uh tasks that
you need to execute and you need to do
it several number of times these are
basically executed sequentially it means
one after another so the first treatment
or the function is executed and the next
is taken up so and then the next and so
on so these Loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first task is
done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 2
.4 okay
okay let's see
range as so what I'm going to do is
basically I'm going to fill the column A
from 1 to 24 with some value from 1 to
24 with the values of 1
through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you have it so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up our
an integer a variable X as integer and
we are setting the value of x to be 1 to
24 so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1 and it fills
in A1 and then the next value of x will
be 2 and it goes to A2 and finish the
value as 2. so just let's try to execute
this and you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is 1 to be 24.
okay so this is one basic example of a
purloop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
example by you know executing another
setup for Loop and giving the output and
we'll code the output to be the color
code advance in the column B so how we
do it it's a basic simple example that
I'm going to take and again what I'm
going to do is I will have this values
here and I am going to calculate the
V column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see and
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is if you select it
and it should color the interior with
what
is the color index okay
okay
and the value of x
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the box to be colored and I'm going to
put it as a solid
you can fill this whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
lb
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
you can perform tasks we can perform
with the BBA and this can be found in
detail
Advanced courses let's embark on this
transformative adventure together I hope
I made myself clear with the agenda that
said if you are an aspiring business
analyst looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns post-graduate program and
business analytics from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below also
if you are already a business analyst
and want to upgrade your skills to
become a successful data scientist with
proper training and certification from
the experts and reputed universities
then Caltech data science bootcamp
should be the right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below
So currently I am on my MySQL workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so I'll give my password
I'll click on OK
all right so this is my my SQL workbench
query editor so first we are going to
learn sub queries let me give a comment
and write sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another SQL query that is
embedded within the where Clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries
so for that I'll be using my
database that is SQL underscore intro so
I'll write my command use SQL underscore
intro now this database has a lot of
tables I'll be using the employee stable
that is present inside SQL underscore
intro Let me just expand this and you
can see here we have an employee stable
so let me first show you the contents
within this table I'll write select star
from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee ID employee name each gender
there's date of joint Department City
and salary and we have information for
20 employees if I scroll down you can
see there are 20 employees present in
our table
so let's see you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
the average salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query so let me show you how to write a
sub query
I'll write the select statement
in the select statement I'll pass
my column names that I want to display
so the column names I want are the
employee name
then I want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next I'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
I'll write salary greater than
after this I am going to write my sub
query
so I'll give select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and I'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once you get the average salary number
we'll use this where condition where
salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if I run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is 75 350 dollars
now I want to display all the employees
who have salary greater than 75
350 dollars so let's run our sub query
there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have a salary
greater than the average salary of all
the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
John
let me
run the table once again
okay if I scroll down
you see we have an employee
as John
you see this our employee ID 116 is John
and his salary is sixty seven thousand
dollars I want to display all the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary so basically all the
employees who are earning more than 65
000 I want to print them
so let's see how to do it I'll write
select
I want the employee name comma the
gender of the employee
I also want the department and salary
from my table name that is employees
I'll write where
salary is greater than
I'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket I'm
going to give my inner query that is
Select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is John
So within single quotations I'll give
John as my employee
and end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
John has which is sixty seven thousand
dollars now I want the employees who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see 12 rows returned
which means there are 12 employees in
our table who are earning more than 67
000 you see here all these employees
have a salary greater than sixty seven
thousand dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic models I'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website I'll just show you the
website so this is the website that is
MySQL tutorial.org
you can see here they have very nice
articles blogs from where you can learn
MySQL in detail so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a MySQL sample database if you
click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
MySQL sample database and the name of
the database is classic models all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if I expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have Cricut
customers as employees office this
orders order lines and many more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table first let me show you the
content that is present inside
the products table first
if I run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock Buy price
MSRP
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the details of
all the orders
let me show you
the records
or the details tables has okay so there
are thousand records present in this
table you have the order number the
product code quantity ordered price of
each item you have the order line number
as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products whose price of each product is
less than hundred dollars for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables and we are going to
write a sub query
Okay so
if you see here in the order details
table we have a column called price each
I want to display the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way I'm going to do is
I'll write select
product code comma
product name now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is production order details
here you can see this is the product
code column
comma MSRP which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
I'll write
product
code
I'm going to use the in operator
next I'll write my inner query that is
Select
product code
from my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than
100 dollars
let me run this
okay so you can see there are total 83
products in our table which have
a price less than hundred dollars you
can see the price here
okay
now we learn another Advanced Concept in
SQL which is known as stored procedures
I'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is the
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an SQL code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again save it as a stored procedure
and then call it to execute it
so in this example I want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament
so I have a database called SQL
underscore IQ
these are a few databases that I've
already created so this database has a
table called players if I expand the
tables option you see we have a table
called players and you can see the
columns player ID the name of the player
the country to which the player belongs
to and the number of goals each player
has scored in a particular tournament so
I'll write a stored procedure that will
return the list of top players who have
scored more than six goals in a
tournament so first of all let me Begin
by
using MySQL underscore IQ database
will run it
so now we are inside the SQL underscore
IQ database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are six players in our
table
we have the player ID
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so I'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this it should start with
a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter I'll write
Amberson ampersand
next I'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name let's say I want to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin I'll write my select
statement
I want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from my table that is
players
where
I'll write goals is greater than
six
will give us semicolon
then
I'll end my
procedure with a delimiter that was
double ambison
next
I'll write delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
there should be a space okay
now let's run our stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our store procedure now the way
to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals are not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well now
let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure I'll write call space
followed by the procedure name which is
top underscore players
if I run this you can see we have two
players in our table who have scored
more than six goals so we consider them
as the top place in a particular
tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so I'll give a comment
stored procedure using in parameter
all right
so for this example I'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees based on their
salaries
so if you have a table
in our SQL underscore IQ database which
is called employee details
I am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of join City
and salary
using this table I'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter so let me
show you how to do it
I'll write
delimiter this time I am going to use
forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
for stored procedure
sort by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure I'll give my
parameter
in
I'll create a variable VAR and assign a
data type integer
then I'll write begin
followed by my select statement where
I'll select the name
each
salary
from
my table name that is
EMP details or employee details
I am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
I want to display
limited number of
records so I'm using this
limit keyword and my variable VAR which
I
created here
I learned my select statement
I'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and I'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not here
you have an option to see the stored
procedures let me just refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore clear
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our store procedure I'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by salary
and inside this I'll give my parameter
which was actually VAR and this VAR
we have used in limit
let's say I want to display only the top
three records of the employees who have
the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so Amy Sarah and Jimmy but
the top three employees who have the
highest salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement and we
called our stored procedure and passed
in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select statement inside
stored procedure you can also use other
statements let's say update
so I'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of Select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the in
operator twice so let me show you how to
do it
I'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be forward slash
then I'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the update salary name
I'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
I'll assign is worker 20
I'll again use my in parameter I'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
I'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement I'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and I'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if I refresh this
you can see I have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all I'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table okay
so we have six rows of information let's
say you want to update the salary of
employee Jimmy or let's say
Mary
from 70 000 to let's say 72 000.
for let's say eighty thousand so I'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time I'm going to pass in two
parameters the first parameter will be
the employee name and next with a comma
I'll give my new salary that I want to
so my employee name let's say is Mary
and the salary I want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
I'll give a semicolon
and I'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go if you see this record for
maybe we have successfully updated the
salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learned to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter so I'll give a
comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
will create total employees as an output
parameter and the data type would be an
integer the count of the female
employees is assigned to the output
variable which is total underscore emps
using the into keyword let me show you
how to write a stored procedure using
the out parameter
so first I'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be SP underscore
count
employees
and inside this I am going to give my
out parameter and the variable name that
is total underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next I am going to write begin
followed by my select statement that is
Select I want the
count of total employees
and the output I am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is EMP underscore
details
where
sex is equal to
F which means female
I'll go by semicolon
next I'll end it
with the developer and I am going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what I am doing here
I am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure I am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
EMP underscore details so I've used my
out parameter and I am creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer
here in the select statement I am
counting the names of the employees and
the result I am storing it in total
underscore emps
I have used my wear condition where the
gender of the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure let's refresh this
okay you can see we have our new stored
procedure SP underscore count employees
now
call it I'll write call
the name of the procedure that is Count
underscore SP underscore count
employees
within brackets I'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
F underscore EMP
I'll give a semicolon then I'll write
select
at the rate F underscore
EMP as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first I'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next Topic in this
tutorial on Advanced SQL now we are
going to learn about triggers in SQL
so I'll give a
comment here
reverse in SQL
so first let's understand what is a
trigger so a trigger is a special type
of stored procedure that runs
automatically when an event occurs in
the database server
there are mainly three types of triggers
in SQL we have the data manipulation
trigger we have the data definition
trigger and login triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the student's rule
number the age the name and the students
marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than 0 a
trigger will automatically set the marks
to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so I'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
roll number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or varying character
size I am giving it as 30 finally we
have the marks as floating type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created a table
now
I'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time I'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is Mark
underscore
let's say verify
I am going to use a before insert
trigger so I'll write before insert
on my table name that is student
next I'll write for each row
if
new DOT marks
is less than zero
then
we'll set
new DOT
marks equal to 50.
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 we'll assign a value
50 to that student because usually the
marks are not less than 0 in any exam
I'll write end if
semicolon and I'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command I'll run it
it says trigger already exists so in
this case we need to update the trigger
name let's say
I'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for St
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is Mark and
not marks so here we need to change it
as Mark instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so I'll write insert into student
I'll write
values
and give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10 the name is it's a
root
and the marks is let's say 75 point
if a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student rule number is 502
age is 12
the name is let's say Mike
and this time I'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the Third
record
for student rule number 503
ages 13
the name is Dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by Dave is
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
these is 10.
name I'll enter as Jacobs
and this time again I'm purposely giving
the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket and give a semicolon
and I'll run my insert statement okay so
we have inserted four rows of
information to our student table
now
let me run the select query I'll write
select star from student
if I run this you see the difference
there you go
so originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504 for Jacobs the marks
was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
Max underscore big Pi underscore St
I'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial Concept in SQL which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
I'll give a comment as views in SQL
okay
now
to learn views I am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as I mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so I'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so I'll write select
star from customers
okay I missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address State country and other
information
now I'll write a basic view command
using this customer table the way to
write is I'll write create
View
followed by The View name which is cast
underscore details
then you write as
select
I am going to select a few column names
from my original customer table which is
this one so I need the customer name
let's say I need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number
and the City
all right
I'll write from my table that is
customers
if I run this
my view the discussed details will be
created
let's run it there's some error here
because the name of the table is
customers and not customer
I'll give an S and I'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view I can write select star
from followed by The View name that is
custom details
please
run it
there you go so we have the customer
name the phone number and the City of
the different customers that you have in
our table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that I am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table I'm talking about the products
table and the product lines table
present inside classic models database
so before I start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description and there's some HTML
description and image
so
I'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing create
View
followed by The View name that is
product underscore
description
as I'll write
select
product
name
comma
then I'll write
quantity
in stock
I also want the MSRP
now these three columns are present
inside the products table and next from
the
product line stable I want the text
description
of the products
so I'll write from
products table
I'll give an alias as p
followed by Inner join my other table
that is
product lines as let's say TL
on
the common column that is product line
so P Dot
product line
is equal to
I'll give a space
PL Dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description let us run it all right so
we have our view ready
now let me
View
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
View
I'll add select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn textual
descriptions of the different products
in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view instead of product
underscore description you want to give
some other name
so I'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement I'll write rename table
product
underscore description Which is my
old name
I want to change this name to let's say
I'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so I'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see I have
renewed my
View
so here if I just refresh it and I'll
expand this you can see we have the cash
details view and we have the vehicle
underscore description View
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
I'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use so
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
I'll write View
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error this
should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so I'll write drop
view followed by The View name let's say
I want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
I'll write draw View cast underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cast underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about Windows functions
now Windows functions were Incorporated
in MySQL in the 8.0 version
so Windows function in MySQL are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my SQL underscore intro
database
so we'll find the total combined salary
of the employees for each department
so first let me switch my database to
SQL underscore
intro database
I'll run it okay
I'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we'll partition our table by department
and print the total salary and this we
are going to do using
some windows functions in MySQL
so I'll write
select
I want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next I'll write
the sum of salary
over
I want to partition it by
Department
so I'll write Partition by Department
which is Dept
and I'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go so here we have created
another column in our result that is
total salary and for each of the
employees and the respective departments
you have the highest salary so in
finance the highest salary of one of the
employees was
155 000 dollars
similarly if I come down we have the
highest salary from HR if I scroll
further we have the highest salary from
it marketing product sales and the tech
team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function I'll write
select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so I'll write order by salary
I'll give the
Alias as ronum
we give a comma
and I want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees
and I'll order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a ronum column and we have
successfully given row numbers to each
of the records you can see it starts
from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first I'll create a table
I'll write create table
let's say I'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's see we have in this table the
student ID which is of type integer and
we have the student name
which is of type worker
the size is 20. I'll create the small
table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so I'll write insert
into
demo
values
I'll give 101
the name is
Shane
give a comma
I'll insert the second student name 102
the name is
Bradley
give a comma
this time
for one zero three we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
hirath
you give a comma I'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated one zero three
next we have one zero four
the name of the student that says
Nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student which is Kevin we have
two records
I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you I'll write select
star from demo
if you see this we have a few
information that are duplicated in our
table
that is for student id103 and student ID
105.
now I am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table I'll write
select student underscore ID comma
student underscore name
I'll give another comma and write
Rue underscore number
over
within brackets
I'll write partition
by
St underscore ID
comma
St underscore name
okay
then I'll write
order by St underscore ID
close the bracket I'll give an alias as
ronum
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right if you see here there is just
one student in the name Shane we have
one student in the name Bradley but here
if you see for herath
the second record it says to which means
there are two records for hirath and if
I scroll down there is one record for
Nathan and there are two records for
Kevin which means Kevin is also repeated
okay
now we are going to see another Windows
function that is called rank function
in MySQL so the rank function assigns a
rank to a particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
rank values when two or more rows have
the same rank so first of all let me
create a table
and the name of the table would be a
random name will give it as let's say
demo one
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so I'll write
value
one zero one
zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
I'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
next we have one zero four
one zero five
we have one zero six
and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo one okay this is done
now
if I write
select
VAR underscore a
and use my rank function I'll write rank
over
then I'll
order by my variable that is VR
underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo one
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if I run this there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test tank is 2 but
for this value which is 1 0 3 the test
rank is repeated because there was a
repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank 4 here for
104 the rank is 5 now for one zero five
the rank is six now
for 106 again since the record was
repeated twice we have skipped the
eighth Rank and
our rank function assigned the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value one zero seven
the rank is 9.
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final Windows function which is
called first value
so first value is another important
function in MySQL so this function
Returns the value of the specified
expression with respect to the first row
in the window frame
all right
so what I'm going to do is
I am going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and I'll write
first underscore
value which is my function and pass in
my employee name
and then I'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
I'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is employees
so let me run this and see how the
first
underscore value function works all
right so in our table
Joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
I'll write select EMP underscore name
comma
I want the department
and the salary
comma
I'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
I'll write over
here I am going to use partition
I am going to partition it by
department since I want to know the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department
and I am going to order by
salary descending
and I'll give my Alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's run this and see the difference
in the output okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for freelance
Jack had the highest salary from HR it
was Marcus similarly in it it was
William
if I scroll down for marketing it was
John a product it was Alice who had the
highest salary similarly in sales we had
Joseph
and in Tech we had Angela so this is how
you can use the first underscore value
function using partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learned about sub queries in SQL so
we initially wrote a simple sub query
and then we used our classic models
database which was downloaded from the
internet and also shown you the link
from where you can download this
database here we used two different
tables and we performed a sub query
operation
we learned how to create stored
procedures
so we learned how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter in stored procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another crucial Concept in SQL which is
called triggers now triggers are also
special kind of stored procedures so we
saw how to write a before insert trigger
you can see it here
next
we learned how to delete a trigger we
also saw how to work with views in SQL
so views are basically virtual tables
that you can create from existing tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learned how to display views how to
rename
view names
how to delete a view and finally we
explored a few Windows function X is a
journey that involves a combination of
skills Advanced analogies locations and
processes used by a firm gain business
insights from data and statistic
this is done to perform business
planning
in the analytics process data is
collected from various external sources
and is stored in a data warehouse
after this data collection the process
of analytics begins
here a more in-depth learning of the
data is done to derive possible insights
from data
in addition to this all advanced
data-driven capabilities are developed
which in turn provides additional value
to business
in the next slide we will look at the
places where analytics is applied
of the common fields where analytics is
implemented are as follows
Financial Services
in this field analytics is used for
credit scoring fraud detection pricing
and claims analysis
in retail it is used for promotions
replenishment demand forecasting and
Merchandising optimization
in healthcare it is used for drug
interaction
preliminary diagnosis and disease
management
customer retention capacity planning and
network optimization are the primary
applications in the field of
communications
trading Supply demand forecasting and
compliance are the areas of application
in energy
in manufacturing it is used for
inventory replenishment
product customization and supply chain
optimization
in the next slide we will look at the
topics that are covered in the first and
second lessons
in lesson one you will learn what
analytics is and understand the process
involved in it
the lesson will also provide brief
details on where you can apply analytics
and what insights can be derived from
this application
this helps you in understanding a
problem and knowing how a data scientist
should act
this lesson will also help you in
knowing how to collect data and prepare
it for your analytical process
in the second lesson you will have an
overview of all statistical methods
including descriptive statistics
probability Theory concepts of test of
significance and hypothesis testing
some business uses of these statistical
Concepts have also been provided via
case studies for better understanding
this lesson will give you an idea of how
you can derive some meaningful pattern
from the data
it will help you in finding the
distribution pattern that is hidden in
the data and in proceeding with further
decisions that are to be made at the
basic level
in the next slide we will look at the
topics that will be covered in the third
and fourth lessons
third lesson will help you understand
data exploration data visualization and
diagnostic analytics and perform these
using the r tool
case studies and examples have been
provided to help you understand the
concepts in a practical way and also
help you use the r tool effectively
the fourth lesson will help you
understand some predictive techniques
such as regression analysis and models
that could be built from them
logistic regression time series analysis
and cluster analysis will also be taught
with some example case studies
these predictive modeling techniques
will help you look at the past data and
identify the predicted value that helps
in making decisions
further all the working procedures are
explained using the r tool in a stepwise
manner with suitable examples
in the next slide we will look at the
career path of a business analyst
the of analytics has evolved over time
and the Advent of big data has made
analytics one of the most sought after
skills in the industry across domains
this course will help you take the first
step toward understanding analytics and
the way it interfaces with the industry
the course will also help you start
thinking like a business analyst
career-wise you can aspire to be a data
manager data Miner or a business manager
the work of a data manager involves
data preparation
deployment Services report
Administration
the work of a data Miner involves
exploratory analysis
descriptive segmentation
predictive modeling
the work of a business manager involves
campaign management
domain expertise
process and Roi evaluation
this includes Lesson Zero of the
business analytication with our tools
course offered by impleawlearn thank you
for your attention
please continue your learning with
lesson one of this course
hello and welcome to one of the business
analytics foundation with our tools
course offered by simple learn
after completing this course you will be
able to differentiate between analysis
and analytics understand what is
analytics learn the different stages in
Analytics
know the popular tools used in Analytics
understand the role of a data scientist
no the process is involved in analytics
Define a problem statement
collect and summarize data
detect and treat outliers in the data
we all know we are learning about
analytics then what is analysis is it by
any means different from analytics if
yes in what ways is it different in this
slide we see the basic difference
between analytics and Analysis
analytics is the science of analysis
wherein we apply methods of Statistics
Data Mining and computer technology for
doing an analysis
whereas analysis is the process in which
the complex data available has been
broken down to simpler forms which
provide more Compact and better data for
understanding
in the next slide we will see more into
what is Analytics
so what actually is analytics it's the
science of wisely acquiring meaningful
results from the given data using
various methods and Technologies and by
which a pattern of variation is observed
by studying this pattern we can
understand the future and predict the
uncertainty that is related to business
various sophisticated models and
techniques are used like statistical
mathematical and economical models
so how do you go about analytics
first you gather data for example for a
commercial entity you collect data from
Enterprise social media internet forums
Etc second you Club all the data
together and consolidate and organize it
in a form from which you can analyze
through visualization statistics
Etc which is the third step in the
process
in the next slide we will see the
different stages of Analytics
there are major four stages in any
analytics work
the first stage is called descriptive
analytics where data or information is
gathered and summarized this stage
usually caters to questions like how
many students dropped out last year
the next stage is called diagnostic
analytics where data is analyzed and
insights are generated
which help in answering the questions in
the first stage
here the question that comes up will be
why has the dropout rate increased in
the last one year
with the help of the analysis done in
the previous two stages the next stage
tries to answer unforeseen phenomena
like which students are most likely to
drop out this stage is called Predictive
Analytics
finally the last stage known as
prescriptive analytics tries to analyze
the type of action required to be taken
to support or avoid the unforeseen
phenomena predicted in the previous
stage
in this scenario prescriptive analytics
has queries like which students should I
Target to keep them from dropping out
next we will look at a list of a few
popular tools used in Analytics
these are some of the commonly used
tools for analytical purpose to get
meaningful results
are
Revolution r
Studio
tableau
sap Hana
wakea
kxen
SAS
next we will discuss the role of a data
scientist
so what is the role of a data scientist
in data analytics
a data scientist is somebody who is
inquisitive who can look at data and
spot Trends they come out with
unrevealed stories hidden in data that
helps in creating more useful insights
and thus help in solving business
problems
a data scientist Works in sync with
application developer to get the
relevant data for analysis
he or she makes an analytical plan in
such a way that the results satisfy the
business needs
a data scientist also comes up with an
effective data mining architecture and
prepares suitable models they are
responsible for resolving data mining
performance issues
and finally they should generate reports
that are affordable from a business
perspective next we will see the
methodology involved in data analytics
the data analytics methodology comprises
of six steps as can be seen in the image
the discovery step is questioning if
there is sufficient data to make an
analytical plan once we have the data in
data preparation all unstructured data
is converted into structured data so
that it helps in planning
model planning is choosing an
appropriate model that suits your data
model building is building the model
that is being specified in the previous
step the next step is to come up with
insights that help customers to solve
their problems that is to deliver
results
the final step is to make the model
operational and put the findings to use
next we will discuss how to define the
problem
defining the problem statement is an
important step in analytics and needs to
be done before starting the project at a
high level the problem statement should
answer for basic questions
what is the problem find the existing
problem that needs to be solved
what is it not Define the problem that
is not being caused
why do we have this problem find the
root cause of the problem
why don't we have a solution this gives
the answer that is why the problem could
not be resolved
in the next slide we will discuss how to
formally Define a problem statement the
techniques that are involved in formally
defining a problem are State the problem
in a general way that is State the
problem in general terms with respect to
some practical scientific or
intellectual interest
the next step is to understand the
nature and origin of the problem its
objectives and the environment in which
the problem is to be studied
next all available literature including
relevant theories reports records and
any form of relevant literature on the
problem needs to be reviewed and
examined
the next step is optional the researcher
may discuss the problem with his or her
colleagues and others related to the
concerned subject to brainstorm ideas
finally rephrase the problem that is put
the problem in specific terms that make
it feasible and helps in the development
of working hypotheses
next we will look at ways to summarize
data
before summarizing data the types of
data need to be discussed data can be
two types
qualitative or quantitative qualitative
or categorical data refers to data that
are descriptive they are generally
recorded in groups or in descriptive
language example dividing people into
high medium and low height groups
quantitative or numeric data refers to
data that are recorded in numbers they
could be either continuous or discrete
variables example the measured height of
a person
in the next slide we will discuss how to
analyze this data
summarizing refers to procedures that
are applied on the raw data to convert
them into an easily readable and
analyzable format the mathematical
summaries differ according to the type
of data numerical or categorical and
fall into descriptive and graphical
categories seen here is an example of
population divided by marital status a
bar chart has been used to depict the
same data in the next slide we will see
the different summaries based on the
categories
numeric data can be summarized using the
mean median and mode values
these are discussed in detail in the
following chapters along with other
methods for summarizing
categorical data can be summarized using
a frequency distribution table that is
the number of occurrences of a value for
all values graphical representations
help in Easy visualization of the data
numeric variables can be viewed as box
plots and the categorical variables can
be viewed in bar charts or histograms
the visualizations will be discussed in
detail in the following chapters
in the next slide we will discuss how to
collect data
data collection is the process of
gathering data that is relevant to the
problem statement at hand
the data AIDS improving or disproving
hypotheses or provide solutions to a
research or a problem statement
regardless of the problem the data
collection process needs to be well
defined and systematic
in an effort to construct accurate data
the accuracy of the data is the primary
factor in deciding the validity of the
findings
depending on the method used to collect
data the observations need to be
recorded and organized in such a way to
provide Optimum usefulness
the recording and organization of data
must also be directly related to the
methods of analysis and use of the data
we will see the methods of collecting
data in the next slide
the data collection methods fall into
two major categories
primary and secondary
observations experiments and surveys
fall into the primary category
observations refer to measuring the data
and various attributes in experiments
the subjects are divided into groups
receive different external input and the
results are recorded
surveys questionnaires and interviews
help in recording feedback and are used
in studying the characteristics of a
population
data sources refer to data that have
already been gathered and are available
in a published format reporting refers
to cases where there exists a database
of information that can be legally
obtained
next we will discuss data dictionary
a data dictionary also called a metadata
repository is a file that describes the
structure and content of the data
the data dictionary is a file or a list
of files that contains data about the
database like
number of Records name of each field
characteristic and type of each field
description of each field relationships
between different fields
in analysis the data dictionary helps in
analyzing different variables and the
relationships and dependencies between
each other
in the next slide we will discuss the
final topic of this lesson outliers
outliers are observation points in
addition
deviates from other observations if you
look at the graph it plots the marks
obtained as a result of a particular
study time the trend is that marks
increase as the students study longer
except for one marked point this could
be a possible outlier outliers could
exist in a distribution due to erroneous
observations or special circumstances
like a bulk sales order on a particular
day in a store
outlier detection tests exist to check
for outliers that are model based and
generally look for outliers based on
mean and variance of the data outliers
can be excluded from the analysis or
included while using algorithms that
treat outliers as well
there are other outlier treatments but
are out of scope for this chapter
let us quickly summarize what we have
learned in this lesson we have discussed
what analytics and Analysis are and the
differences between them
popular tools used in analytics what a
data scientist does the processes
involved in the analytics lifecycle how
to formally Define a problem statement
methods of collecting and summarizing
data for Analytics
data dictionary and its contents what
outliers are and how to detect and treat
them
the section will help you to check your
understanding of the concepts covered in
the last two decades have witnessed
extensive business infrastructure
Investments due to this the capability
of collecting data has improved across
Enterprises while some businesses
continue to operate in their traditional
ways in other businesses each aspect is
now virtually open to collect data these
aspects are even instrumented for data
collection aspects like Supply Chain
management marketing campaign
performance manufacturing operations and
workflow procedures are a few examples
simultaneously information is also
available on events like industry news
market trends and movements of
competitors
the wide availability of data has led to
increasing interest in methods to
extract useful information from data
science
with this data availability
organizations in almost each industry
are focused to exploit data for their
advantage over competitors
earlier organizations used to employ
different teams of analysts modelers and
statisticians for manually exploring
data sets however now the variety and
volume of data have outstripped the
manual analysis capacity computers have
also become powerful and networking has
become widespread also algorithms are
being developed that can help connecting
various databases to allow powerful data
analysis as a result of all these
phenomena various data science
principles and data mining techniques
are coming into existence
a manager in an organization needs to
take several decisions on the basis of
the problem and alternative courses of
action available to conclude the best
option they need all the information
that is relevant and the Criterion to
choose the best option here's a set of
questions that can be important for any
business executive
some other interesting questions that
could be important to business
executives are also listed on the screen
let's first understand what business
analytics is it's a scientific process
that transforms data into Insight it
takes data from various sources and
various types and convert them into
insights that improve support and
automate decisions
the techniques used for this process are
presentation technological and
quantitative in other words it's a
process that uses data for better
decision making it's used for fact-based
or data-driven decision making this is
generally considered as more objective
as compared to other decision-making
alternatives
business analytics uses simple tools
such as reports and graphs and also
complex tools such as optimization Data
Mining and simulation in the graph shown
on the screen we've compared different
data analytics techniques in terms of
competitive advantage and degree of
complexity prescriptive analytics offers
the most competitive advantage over
other techniques such as descriptive and
predictive however performing
prescriptive analytics is the most
complex data analytical technique we'll
look into details of each of these
techniques in the subsequent screens
let's now talk about the features of
business analytics or ba the first
important feature is the support to
various methodologies these include
Concepts from applied probability
Applied Mathematics applied statistics
and computer science since it's used by
organizations that are committed to
data-driven decision making the data
produced helps in gaining meaningful
insights into better business planning
and business performance
the next important feature is decision
support systems in data-driven companies
data is treated as a corporate asset
successful analytics is dependent upon
the quality of data and analysts who
know the business and Technologies
Solutions are primarily used as decision
support systems or as their components
the solutions help Executives
salespeople and other organizational
leaders to make business decisions
another important feature of business
analytics is business continuity support
as business analytics supports essential
business functions and also supports
tactical decision making with respect to
unforeseen events it also AIDS in
functions such as hiring reducing
attrition improving retention performing
staff deployment and deciding strategy
in many cases decision making is
automated for supporting responses in
real time
this lesson will help you understand the
concepts related to different types of
business analytics such as descriptive
analytics Predictive Analytics
prescriptive analytics supply chain
analytics Healthcare analytics marketing
analytics Cuban resource analytics and
web Analytics
descriptive analytics analyzes the past
events and predicts the approach of
future it analyzes the past performance
by mining the past data and look for the
reasons why past failures or successes
happen almost all management reporting
such as Finance operations marketing and
sales uses this Analytics the related
models quantify data relationships in a
manner that is generally used for the
classification of customers and
Prospects into various groups for
instance these models can be used to
classify customers on the basis of their
preferences and life stages they can be
used to create further models that can
make predictions and can stimulate
various individualized agents some of
the data techniques used by this
analytics includes reports data mining
techniques descriptive statistics data
queries data dashboards and basic
what-if spreadsheet models
Predictive Analytics converts data into
actionable and usable information it
determines the possible future outcome
of an event or the possibility of a
situation it includes various
statistical techniques from machine
learning data mining modeling and Game
Theory and include techniques that use
models created from past data to predict
the future or determine the impact of
one variable on another
when it comes to businesses these models
use the patterns found in transactional
and historical data for identifying
opportunities and risks they allow risk
assessment by capturing relationships
between various factors the three basic
cornerstones of this analytics are
predictive modeling and decision
analysis and optimization and
transaction profiling an example to use
this analytics can be to optimize
customer relationship Management Systems
some other examples include a company
that can create a mathematical model for
predicting the future sales by using
past data on product sales and a food
manufacturing company that can estimate
the measurement and quality of unit
sales by using the point of sale scanner
data from retail outlets
a few other examples include an
organization that can predict the market
share of a new product by using the
survey data and past purchase Behavior
using Predictive Analytics these
organizations can analyze the spending
use and behavior of customers this leads
to effective cross sales and high
profitability an organization must
employ an experts team or data
scientists to find and access the
appropriate data this team can work with
Business Leaders for Designing business
strategies by using Predictive Analytics
techniques such as time series analysis
linear regression data mining techniques
and simulation or risk analysis
prescriptive analytics uses mathematical
Sciences machine learning business rules
and big data for making decisions and
suggesting decision options it specifies
the best course of action for a business
activity in the form of the output of a
prescriptive model it goes beyond
predicting the outcomes of future and
also suggests the action to benefit from
the predictions it anticipates the
reason of an incident and not just what
and when it will happen it can also
suggest decision options on the method
to take the benefit of a future
opportunity or to mitigate a risk of the
future the models used in this analytics
are called optimization models and
combine various business rules
mathematical models and data the input
can be internal data external data and
various other sources
here are some example Industries in
which this analytics is used
the airline industry can benefit by
using Revenue management models and past
purchasing data as inputs to get the
best pricing strategy across all flights
similarly the finance industry can use
portfolio models that utilize historical
investment return data to decide the mix
of Investments
other examples of prescriptive analytics
are supply network design models in
operations and price markdown models in
retailing in operations supply network
design models provide cost minimizing
plant and distribution center locations
retailing used price markdown models
that provide the timing of discount
offers and revenue maximizing discount
levels
one of the traditional analytics
applications was in Supply Chain
management and Logistics it's used at
the core of companies like FedEx and UPS
it's used for efficient delivery and
optimal sorting of goods it's also used
for vehicle and staff scheduling vehicle
routing better inventory and processing
control and efficient Supply chains
analytic tools used in this area span
the complete analytics Spectrum for
instance it's been used by the women's
apparel manufacturer Bernard Clause Inc
the company used a descriptive analytics
for presenting its supply chain status
to its managers another example is
ConAgra Foods a packaged Foods company
which used prescriptive and Predictive
Analytics for planning its capacity
utilization better by including the
inherent uncertainty in Commodities
pricing the company received 100 return
on their investment in analytics in less
than three months
analytics and Healthcare is used to
simultaneously control cost and provide
more effective treatment to patients
predictive prescriptive and descriptive
analytics are used to improve staff
patient and facility scheduling they're
also used to control inventory
purchasing and patient flow for instance
as per the McKinsey Global Institute or
MGI and McKinsey and Company 14 study by
better utilizing analytics the United
States Health Care system could save
more than 300 billion each year which is
equivalent to the complete gross
domestic product of countries such as
Singapore Finland and Ireland
marketing is one of the expanding areas
to apply analytics a better
understanding of customer Behavior by
using data generated from social media
and scanner data leads to several
advantages such as better use of
advertising budgets effective pricing
strategies improved demand forecasting
better product line management and
increased customer satisfaction and
loyalty one of the example is automobile
manufacturer Chrysler tamed with JD
Power and associates they developed
predictive models for supporting their
pricing decisions for automobiles says
they helped Chrysler to better
understand the ramifications of proposed
pricing structures the models generated
an estimated annual Savings of 500
million dollars
the use of analytics and the human
resources area is relatively new with
the use of analytics the HR function
ensures that the organization employs
the required skill sets to meet its
needs hires the highest quality Talent
provides an employee retention
environment and achieves its
organizational diversity objectives
Sears Holding Corporation or shc is an
example in this area it created an HR
analytics team inside its corporate HR
function that used descriptive and
Predictive Analytics to support employee
hiring and tracking and influencing
retention
web analytics is the analysis of online
activity such as visiting websites and
social media sites like LinkedIn and
Facebook it has huge implications for
promoting and selling products and
services through the internet
some points to remember are that leading
companies use descriptive and advanced
analytics to data collected in online
experiments for determining the best way
for configuring websites position ads
and using social networks to promote
products and services
online experimentation includes exposing
various subgroups to various website
versions and tracking the results these
experiments prove to be ineffective as
they allow the company to use the trial
and error method in statistically
determining what makes a difference in
their website traffic and sales
why is decision making in any business
very important the goal of business
decision making is to high Revenue low
costs and low expenses it's supported by
business analytics in various ways such
as for increasing Revenue while keeping
selling expenses the same business
analytics suggests changes in the
Salesforce deployment and can also be
used if a company's employees are
leaving voluntarily for higher paying
jobs and there are high onboarding costs
in such cases business analytics
recommends raises that can help retain
existing employees
business intelligence or bi refers to
reporting and analytics tools
traditionally used for determining
historical data Trends these techniques
and tools are used to transform raw data
into useful information for the purpose
of business analysis it includes a set
of processes methodologies Technologies
and architectures that uses the output
of the information management processes
the Technologies can handle large
amounts of unstructured data for
identifying and developing and otherwise
creating new strategic business
opportunities bi enables queries by
which users can get results by asking
data related questions it allows easy
data interpretation of high amounts of
data while implementing an effective
strategy based on insights that can help
a business gain a competitive advantage
bi includes tools that are designed to
present the results of analytics in an
understandable format they provide
historical current and predictive views
of business operations
some functions include online analytical
processing process mining prescriptive
analytics text mining business
Performance Management and benchmarking
data science includes processes
principles and methods to understand
phenomena through automated data
analysis it allows data-driven decision
making or DDD which determines the
productivity of an organization DDD is
the practice of basing decisions on data
analysis instead of just intuition
organizations get involved in DDD to
lesser or greater degrees which decides
the productivity of the organizations
the given image shows how data science
interacts with the outer world
let's now talk about the importance of
data science you can consider data
science a business asset that is about
data investment and understanding of its
fundamental concepts is required for
data scientists and anyone working with
data scientists employing data
scientists investing in data heavy
Ventures or directing an analytics
application in an organization
DDD and Big Data Technologies improve
business performance substantially data
science supports DDD and at times
performs such decision making
automatically
with respect to data science the key
strategic assets are data and the
ability to extract useful information
from data many businesses use data
analytics to get value from the existing
data and to generally consider if the
business has the right analytical Talent
incorrect data and unsuitable data
science Talent results in issues such as
poor decisions
Big Data typically refers to data sets
that are too large for traditional data
processing systems as Technologies are
considered as a popular platform for
data analytics and data exploration and
used to implement data mining techniques
and data processing
these Technologies are also used to
process data in support of the data
mining techniques and other data science
activities nowadays companies that
employ Big Data technologies have
started asking what can I now do that I
couldn't do before or do better than I
could do before
therefore it's possible the Golden Era
of data science
different types of analytical tools
available are listed on the screen these
are open source software have object
oriented design and can be linked with
General programming platforms they also
offer extensibility and various other
features
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together I hope I made myself
clear with the agenda that said if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
post-graduate program and business
analytics from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below also if you are
already a business analyst and want to
upgrade your skills to become a
successful data scientist with proper
training and certification from the
experts and reputed universities then
Caltech data science bootcamp should be
the right choice for more details use
the link in the description box below
business analyst view question
my name is Richard kirschner with the
simply learned team get certified get
ahead
we'll go over some beginner intermediate
and advanced level questions to expect
in interviews when you're looking at
business Analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question dealing with business because
in business they want to make money and
we really want to understand where the
split is on a lot of these things so
always ask yourself where is the bottom
dollar on this and what does this mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening so
risk is a potential problem that can be
predicted risk me or may not happen in
the future a proactive response plan is
formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there's no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company specific and so when you start
looking for work you start going in for
interviews you should start really
asking yourself what are these companies
looking for that I'm interested in
clearly if you work with IBM you want to
have your tools that are Central to IBM
and the IBM setup same thing with Google
with you know just across the whole
field some of the more basic ones
obviously an Excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list but your python your
SQL you should really know your SQL is
going to come up and no matter what
format you're in your Tableau your Azure
your balsamic all these are different
platforms there's a lot more out there
but you should be aware on which
platforms your proficiencies are on and
those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and a lot of
companies will pay for you to be
certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand any one of these in a little
bit more detail than just knowing the
list what is feasibility study a
feasibility study is a method of gauging
the success rate of proposed Business
Solution it enables a business analyst
to discover new business opportunities
and really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at it for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up in
most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done what is business model
analysis business model analysis is a
technique that helps you analyze if a
business is financially economically and
socially viable or not
I know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in Colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that so it's a very high-end job
Niche we really need to know your stuff
and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs we look at requirements
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set business
objectives business requirements are
data used for business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result business needs include
identifying and comprehending the
businesses goals and articulating its
strategic direction and you can think of
needs are what do we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip PIN codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using Excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes PIN codes of various cities from
the US and India here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing City from
the field list click on the insert data
option and select state from the field
list
really you do need to know your way
around Excel no matter what other
packages you're working with Excel is
such a base package in business analysis
so much people are given that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
Baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in India
you can use the sum IF function to find
the total revenue generated from India
you see here equals some f and then of
course B2 to B 100 India L2 to l1001 and
that will give you the sum you can also
use a filter option to filter the data
only for India and use subtotal by
pressing alt plus equals nice short
hotkey to remember there
create a highlight table to visualize a
revenue generated from offline and
online sales for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies use tab blue but
it is becoming a very highly used tool
because it's so easy to use you drag the
region onto columns drag the cells
Channel and item type Fields onto rows
select the total revenue column and drag
it on to color and label cards select
Square as the mark type
drag the total revenue field onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows Place item type column onto
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select Asia
so one of the things about tab blue is
it looks real complicated but it's all
drag and drop and so you should know
your way around about doing some very
simple drag and drops for doing your
query in summation and below is the
resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
uh differentiate between software
development lifecycle and Project Life
Cycle
if you're looking a little bit more
hierarchical towards the top of the list
software development life cycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases here
phases include requirement Gathering
coding operations maintenance and
documentation
where the Project Life Cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business Project Life Cycle consists
of multiple software and one customer
scenario phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
Analysis how do you perform risk
management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull tables across we're going to
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced assessed
and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high risk avoidance whereas risk
avoidance is carried out to avoid the
risk from occurring meanwhile the
business impact here is zero and the
cost is fully eliminated and you can
think about a brick and mortar store and
they have shoplifting you want to
mitigate as you want to avoid as much
shoplifting as you can but you can only
Frisk people at the door and have
security so much before you start losing
customers and so when you mitigate it
you're going to have to pay for your
lost merchandise where you avoid it you
have your security cameras and people
watching to stop people from stealing
things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent badly spent on equipment
certifications there's all kinds of
areas where you want to mitigate and
avoid risk
what are project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model two of our biggest or
most basic models used today the agile
model which is slowly taken over
especially in software the agile model
is adaptable to requirement changes and
has an incremental approach
in the agile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
and requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
Final Phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall setup you're
not looking for fast changes you're
looking for a very solid it's going to
work no matter what kind of view this is
something that we can build it doesn't
have to make major changes but it better
work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like Moscow and SWAT
Moscow analysis it is a prioritization
technique that highlights a requirement
significance question like is it a
must-have or I should have could the
demand be made better would a specific
idea be useful in the future are asked
here
in the SWOT analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
SWOT analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats and
you cannot kind of think of it as like
the SWAT team coming in
to you know you're worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in Moscow really what is
um what can we get out of this you know
is this do we have to have it to succeed
is it going to be useful in the future
so you're looking more for a general
value attached to it list various
components of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives Mission strategies action
plan what is benchmarking benchmarking
is a process of evaluating an
organization's measures like the quality
of policies programs Etc against the
standard criteria
it's so important to have that Baseline
of what are you measuring against the
Baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before I even jump into this I have a
friend who is working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
end location when he arrived they had
been in a fist fight while on their
private plane the stakeholders had so
much difficulty with some particular
aspect going on so difficulties are
going to arise hopefully not at that
level but things happen
and of course you want to just assume
that work with anybody but you want to
listen patiently to the stakeholders
point of view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise comprehend their
worries and be transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and I'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore somebody who's being
difficult but the rest of it is stay
focused stay focused on what you're
trying to accomplish be goal driven this
is a great time to be gold driven not
driven by emotion or the problems that
arise or how the person communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum I go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming XP
feature driven development FDD Crystal
kanban Dynamic systems development
method dsdm if getting your learning
started it's half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
out and having a kind of a general idea
that the other ones are out there is
important to at least know what we're
talking about when someone comes up and
talks about agile
describe the Gap analysis Gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the Gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result Gap
analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities and
you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into Ms
Excel and remember Excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of analysis that we do most of
our data starts in an Excel spreadsheet
or comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an Excel
spreadsheet given below is the employee
text file it has information about name
agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into Excel go to the data tab click on
get data drop down under from file
select text CSV select where the text
file is located in your system and click
on import click on low data imported
into Excel
he had been given sales data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of Statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is go ahead and select a cell in
the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table drag region and item type onto
rows drag total profit onto values sort
the sum of the total profit column
sales table find the percentage
contribution of Cosmetics to the total
revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values right click
on the revenue value under show value as
select percentage of grand total right
click on a profit value under show value
as choose percentage of grand total
and you can see here when we do that we
end up with Cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.94 contribution to the total
profit how do you create a dual axis
chart in Tableau drag the order data
onto columns and convert it into
continuous year drag total revenue onto
rows and total profit to the right
corner of the view until you see the
light green rectangle
synchronize the right axes by
right-clicking on the profit axes under
the marks card change sum total revenue
to bar and sum total profit to line and
adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data Create A View to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has the least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an Excel file
data in Tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column onto rows place the total
profit column under calor and choose the
desired color palette sort the unit sold
axes in descending order
and you can see here it produces a very
quick
boat figure shows a fruit sold and the
least and had the least amount of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
Middle East and North Africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select Middle East and North
Africa
Bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time Iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017. drag
the units sold filled on the columns
drag the region and item type Fields
onto rows under the color card place a
total revenue column drag item type onto
filters and choose clothes meat and baby
food drag the order date column onto
filters and select 2016 and 2017. meat
had the highest units sold it made the
maximum profit now with any of these
Tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
um so that's an important thing to note
we kind of zoomed in on Tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with Tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package that's a good thing so at least
you know what we're talking about and
you've had that hands on
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization we had Moscow
Technique we mentioned that earlier the
requirements are grouped based on must
mandatory should high priority could not
necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100.
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no notional one
hundred dollars to distribute among the
requirements so the 100 method is pretty
similar to what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
picked their top 10 requirements
this is very popular there's a lot of
helpbooks out there about getting things
done they say write everything that you
want to accomplish put them on three by
five cards and narrow it down to five do
those five because once you've conquered
those five then you can move on to the
next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
print burned down
so the Sprint burn down is the chart we
use when you're tracking usually it's in
scrums where that usually comes from the
scrum setup but it's a chart of the work
to be completed and what's still going
on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness time coverage defect
resolution time explain bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
Gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique Which models the
end-to-end business process step the
four essential elements of bpmn are flow
objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim Lanes pool or Lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about Gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews
don't how many times I've been on the
phone calling competition
potential clients to ask questions
so one of the elicitation techniques is
to ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions it can a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis Focus Group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important I just kind of
highlight a few of them that I tend to
get stuck in observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis and you're bringing
people into a workshop and do
observations in the workshop and working
specifically with these people they turn
into potential business growth I tell
you what if you're a shareholder and
someone's doing a business analysis and
they turn around and generate a thirty
thousand dollar sale for your company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
Survey questionnaire survey is my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
listed documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document project Vision
document use cases system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability Matrix
functional requirement document use case
specifications document gap analyst
document describe how you would approach
a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams tracking
the project documenting the progress
and really when you start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here is so important with the
shareholders if you I mean it's great if
you can identify your project goal
that's probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal you
might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams that is such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors this
does not lead to achieving the required
goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following point should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis display
your analysis skills think critically
and I'm going to throw in here the term
from Big Data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes and you need to think critically
you need to really make it what is it
that the shareholders want that's going
to make them understand why this is
important to the business and what does
the business get out of it what is
kanban
Ben helps agile teams in visually
managing work through processes it works
as a scheduling system in agile just in
time production the kanban methodology
is all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
of course when you're working with
kanban you've got to be very careful
about
[Music]
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a
micromanagement being set up where you
want to you want to watch out for that
but you also need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow it has a to do in progress and
done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
any differences between BRD and SRS
BRD business requirements documents is a
high level functional specification of
software BRD is a formal document to
describe the requirement provided by the
client business analysts create this
post their interaction with the clients
SRS system requirement specification is
a high level functional and Technical
specification of software SRS describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas SRS is
created by the systems architects
what is Pareto analysis the Pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal
is also known as the 80 20 rule as per
this rule 82 percent of the projects
benefit arises from 20 percent of the
work vice versa eighty percent of the
case problem can be due to 20 percent of
the causes
differentiate between the V model and
the fish model
we talk about the V model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a V shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step
V model consumes less time and cost the
fish model is similar to The V model but
with more multiple verification teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is compared to the very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage from
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each Region's country that made the
highest revenue
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and Country onto rows place the
total revenue column under values right
click on the country value select the
filter options and choose top ten choose
top 1 as shown above and click on OK
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the sales data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand you need to use an advanced
filter option in Microsoft Excel to
solve this problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select Advanced filter option choose
copy to another location give your
criteria range and the copy to location
we'll click on OK
here's a final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest amount profit create a pivot
table by dragging the region and the
country into rows Place The Profit
column under values right click on any
country value select the filter option
and choose top 10 choose bottom one and
click on OK
let's create a field map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America using Tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under calor and the filters
card drag the region column and select
North America in the filters card drag
the item type column and select
beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see the Greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America
who knew
using Tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters and the total profit
onto color
the above graph depicts the Cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest and really when we're
talking about tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r or you're targeting companies
working in Python you should be able to
quickly do these kind of displays in any
of those packages that you're focused on
Tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also very robust and
easy to use and uses less programming on
the back end so just a quick side note
on there really just leads up if you if
this does not look right to you you're
not able to get through some of these
things make sure you are if that's what
you're targeting in a company for an
interview we have reached the end of the
session on business systems analyst full
course for 2023 should you have any
queries or should you need any
assistance BPD project code and other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you for
watching stay tuned for more from
Central Eagle thank you
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign